[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to a live
coverage of round eight from the uh 2015
US Junior closed Chess Championship here
at the beautiful chess club and
Scholastic Center of St Louis I'm aiv
fredman here with local Grandmaster the
legendary Ben fold hi Ben a and uh yeah
like we say every day we have our dosage
of uh exciting chess really exciting
chess again we think that the cross
table lies a little bit even though it
says four draws and one win you think
maybe the round was a bit dull but no
most draws were very exciting fighting
draws with Misses sometimes to both
sides and uh today is going to be no
different what do you think Ben you mean
we're going to see four draws again no
we're going to see exciting chess again
no we're going to see uh I think a lot
of disli of games today because we're
wrapping up Tom tomorrow tomorrow we
start a little earlier 2 hours earlier
at 11:00 a.m. so this is the last chance
the players get to sleep in so they got
to play exciting chess
today um yeah Chandra Shen players tied
for first playing in round eight right
if we take a look at the standing very
quickly we will see that um in first
place we have a tie between I am AKA
Chandra and F Master Arthur Shen and uh
faith haded that they are paired against
each other um Chandra is having the
white pieces so the burden of proof is
definitely an Arthur a little about 100
points uh lower rated and black uh next
we have in so third place we have I am
Jeffrey Shong one of the main favorites
GM elect uh yesterday he was winning
against Chandra but once again Chanda
proven his uh uh strong resistance in
inferior endings and managed to save a
draw next we have a group of three
players with three and a half points
even an even score and these are I am
Luke Haron vadi F master ruang Lee and F
Master iand leang next we have Michael
bodak and Yan Leu with minus one score
at three
pointsan Leu first uh for the first time
getting a gift from his opponent Kuran
Han yesterday as opposed to giving one a
very rare occasion and next we have mik
Bratton who is really struggling in this
tournament um seems to be decently
prepared but afterwards just loses his
way and closing the table we have Kuran
Han with one and a half points but we
have to say that his last two games were
very impressive draws as a matter of
fact he could have had more than one
point yeah that's right he played very
well his last two rounds and as you said
he could have more points that's right
so the matchups for today Ben we already
mentioned that uh Jeffrey Shong sorry
that Chandra is playing against arur
Shen and we know that Shong is playing
against Michael bodak again another very
very tough match up no Shong is playing
actually under leang oh sorry so who is
B playing uh bodc is black against
Herman
vat oh a shocking Revelation yeah I was
positive that Chong is playing bodc
today all these things happen okay
yeah maybe you're right and the and the
the screens are wrong that's happened
before oh well maybe I'm just wrong
that's also possible yeah so what we can
see it looks like uh well that's board
three that's Sean Leo is playing White
against M Braton which well they're
sitting next to each other uh Ru Fang
Lee is playing Karan Han and yeah we
could see bodc sitting black Carmen V
that's right okay okay so Jeffrey Shan
who's half who's a full point a full
point he's half a point behind Chandra
and Shan and a ahead of everybody else
right is playing oand
leang so very interesting we have our
two-time world youth Champion under
leang playing the highest trated player
and GM like Jeffrey Jong yeah and those
are I mean after today we could see a
three-way tyer first we could see cler
first by a point we could see all kinds
of uh tyer first
right and it was really it's amazing to
think that Chandra who is now a
co-leader and having the white pieces
against Shen basically have everything
in his own hands uh
yesterday even towards the end could
have been just in in Jeffrey's Place
Jeffrey could have been where he is
today and he could have been in uh third
place but he escaped uh proficiently
with a beautiful little trick he managed
to uh embarrass the black Bishop in that
ending and um oh here comes oh yeah here
we go we are going with our own with our
usual ritual and I see that this time my
CER is starting from the left going
right
mm and he's I think that he is
definitely becoming more and more
efficient in
that TSA is
calling I don't know he really didn't
want uh Luke Harman V his hat so I don't
know yeah look at this this is really
watch that this is really thorough no I
think that his mind is on his uh later
evening encounter with that's right and
we're going to probably have mikee caman
later to explain things to us yes he's
going to exactly clarify exactly what's
in the schedule I know that he's going
to be a bit mysterious he promise not to
reveal too much otherwise he's giving
his opponent an advantage but he will
tell a little bit about what's uh what's
up for tonight man Jeffrey didn't even
have the jacket on when he showed up he
put it on afterwards my serious no no
hoodie Wonder's favorite part of the
round Smiley is always other than coming
to visit us all the players want to
visit us because that means they didn't
lose yeah that's right that's right
that's a and the benefit of being in the
studio so yeah round seven we had the
big matchup even bigger matchup in round
eight because aot Chandra and Arthur
Shanner tied for first yeah with well
very different methods of getting there
Chandra with no losses and Shen with no
draws that's right yeah Arthur has five
wins and two losses amazing and
yesterday Arthur took a big risk
sacrificing a pawn out of nowhere
against his opponent uh thinking that
maybe this is a good way to uh muddy the
water and he managed to do that confused
his opponent M and even though the
computer and us like confused us too
yeah exactly and even though we really
really liked uh his opponent's position
he uh yeah B was doing well and then
yeah especially someone so solid as
bodak but I guess Arthur caus enough
complication to
um to confuse his opponent and judging
by the way the players are looking we
have some announcements we once again
see Harmon valotti saying goodbye to man
that also sound like some sort of a
ritual
and Tony Rich are very able TD and
international Arbiter also executive
director of the club is making the last
announcements I'm sure he's reminding
everybody like we do you one more once
more that tomorrow the round starts 2
hours earlier so our show will start
promptly at
10:50 a.m. Central Time with the games
uh starting 10 minutes
later yeah we see taking
pictures yeah please join us tomorrow
for what might be a photo finish ending
mhm all depends on this game yeah the
winner of this game is basically
guaranteed first place tie for first at
the minimum least yeah that's right yeah
potentially based on the other results
could just
be a soul winner yeah I think Arthur
Shen is g to is going to have nine
decisive games that's what you said last
time and you're so far you're close I
mean this round wow it's going to be
tough
we haven't seen around with five
decisive games yet have we no we haven't
four I think was the max yeah we had
some threes twos and the last two have
been one mhm but again with very very
exciting
games so as always we're going to ask
you the lottery question what are your
predictions yes all right I have Arthur
Shen winning of course because he's won
four in a row wow that's that's that's
one you don't agree with I'm I'm not I
don't know if I don't agree I'm
certainly impressed by that commitment
yeah yeah I'm not impressed with aot the
last few rounds so you think that this
time he's going to yeah I think Arthur
is gonna yeah gonna do well today okay I
have Jeffrey Jean winning against Wonder
leang Jeffrey's white and then Le Leo
Bratton I can't imagine any result other
than a draw okay uh Lee versus
Han yeah ruang Lee will'll give him the
nod okay and Harmon vat bodek obviously
a draw a draw okay the the two most
exciting players draw okay okay well
we'll keep that uh in mind for three
decisive results today in several hours
we'll know exactly how you did exactly
how wrong I am well so far you've been
doing so well we decided to buy some
lottery tickets on your advice you've
been writing the numbers and everybody's
buying tickets so that's very
impressive and Tony's finalizing his
statements and very shortly will go on
our
way again we're expecting a very very
exciting run especially in
our major game of the day the two
leaders meeting in round
eight yeah winning here and the your t
for first
that's that's a big prize right at least
yeah at a minimum and going to the US
championship year
yeah yeah if Arthur wins we can BW some
money from
him there's the handshake the handshake
and the clock is what do you expect on
move one little D4 action D4 yes you
guarantee it no and he went D4 we were
close yeah one one one file that's only
one file away oo and Arthur
E5 I don't see a
nidorf so are we expecting a Roy Lopez
and I'm wondering SC Scot Scotch Scotch
Scotch oh well no it's Roy Lopez Bishop
V5 yeah Knight F6 or A6 A6 well answered
yeah no I don't think arur is playing a
berin that's totally not his style way
Bishop A4 open ruy no we never see them
in the Junior and why didn't black play
the schan so we can tell one of our old
jokes now this is to Super Grandmaster
esque I don't like it so I'm wondering
if he's going to try to play the
Marshall and he's going to play anti
Marshall or is it going to be a Brier
let's see so here comes rookie one you
can do an a shot you could also Play
Bishop takes C6 with a delayed exchange
I've seen that in one of the Junior
games but I don't think it was cha
rwi so R Lopez that's what you expected
from this game definitely
not the players seem like they expected
it yeah I think that they are trying to
see who uh who will confuse who first
and we have an interesting position on
the um
xang yeah it's a bononi or well we don't
know yet might be a b we haven't seen a
bon or B this tournament have we no we
have not we don't see a lot of Def very
aggressive approach by a wonderer yeah
he just decides to
play
uncompromisingly he played
G6
okay so he gonna go for
[Music]
bonon it's a good thing Nigel Short's
not
watching not a big fan of the the benon
he's not a big fan of bon no yeah well
we know the famous statement from 20
years ago that in the Bon if God played
God plays God white wins that was a
statement I think of John Nan yeah
didn't he played the Bon a lot with
black he did oh there you go yeah and he
knew after he played Kasparov several
times he
knew okay so the game is developing
shortly slowly now
D6 yeah we haven't seen a bonon this
tournament no okay
next man this is some funny Pierz modern
that I don't understand he played G6
afterwards mhm
wow well it's just a regular pce with C6
yeah it used to be popular this
variation for black used to be popular
F4 some years ago yeah yeah takes takes
G6 I'm not familiar with yeah usually
Bishop G4 was played M and then double
capture we had a lecture uh if only you
would ever lectured here sometimes but
eventually you will I will in August
yeah for the first for the first time
ever yeah uh we had a lecture on this
opening by one of our grandm was in
Residence varac Cobian uhhuh he was
playing Black in this line it's like one
of his like his second or third line
when he's playing against E4 I remember
back in the day it was Bishop G4 white
took on E5 twice black played Knight fd7
yeah I think this might have been a game
that he showed also yeah this I'm not
familiar with taking in G6 I've seen
this before it's also a main
line H3 quickly yeah so this game which
I predicted would be a draw now I'm a
little getting a little scared here yeah
this could be a DEC iive result we'll
see and we have a close Sicilian a
typical position in the closean and
Curran Hanan yeah let's see how this
happened yeah and normally black plays
he Rook to B8 the idea is if Knight G to
E7 then white wants to rush with Bishop
H6 sometimes not that this is so
terrible for black but sometimes black
just doesn't want to allow it so he goes
Rook B8 continues with his plan of
mobilizing the queen side B5 B4 and
eventually white has to make a decision
is he gonna play uh F4 and then kill the
idea of the battery is he gonna play
Knight E2 Knight F3 after which black
can play Knight to D4 attacking C2 and
blocking any attempts to advance D4 by
white so that's the most flexible
continuation and he played Knight G4
right away uh in the old day that was a
mistake you know I wonder now because
now Knight C2 he supposed to play that
move and we'll take a look at this
variation mhm Knight C2 and the idea is
that now you're going to get to play C3
without having developed the Knight on
G1 remember how yesterday in the Luke
Haron velotti in a what seems to be like
almost a reverse close Sicilian he had
to resort to Knight d8 and Knight C8 and
here white usually plays Knight D1 and
Knight C1 here this this move can be
played immediately the point is Knight
takes E2 Knight takes E2 Bishop takes B2
ah but that's usually with the pawn on
E6 I think I think the the he can
probably get away with it because C is
already protected mhm so that might be a
big difference yeah I'm wondering if he
can play Knight D1 immediately though
and then play so how about Knight D1
immediately let's take a look at that
yeah maybe again because the Knight on
G1 hasn't been developed cannot be
traded exactly then white black just has
to retreat right so something about
Knight D4 is a little early yeah yeah
and he did actually make a move and did
he play Knight D1 or no
I I thought I imagined his Knight was on
H3 oh okay that was good good imagining
by me
okay he did make a move though and what
is his move well this is a secret okay
unless he was just writing down his I'm
pretty certain that I would have played
Knight D1 here yeah he did play Knight
D1 yeah I mean I I really don't like
Knight D4 by black I think it's a
mistake right because when you play C3
which happens in this variation a lot
then black can play Knight takes the
Knight on E2 F3 but now you just has to
retreat yeah now he just exactly so a
very strange decision by4 is a little
inaccurate in my opinion he confused his
move order mhm like I said Rook B8 on I
G7 is played
normally okay we'll see how how that
develops it's not a disasterous blunder
but definitely advantageous yeah this
was a game that I was showing uh Ilan a
couple days ago uhhuh yeah it's the
queen C2
nimzo this is Luke's game with Michael
bodc red A3 and yeah this was a game
that I won in the 2001 National op
that's many games that I played but just
to show the audience okay obviously I'll
take with the queen uh in the National
open 2001 in round one my opponent
played Rook E8 and you just took a pawn
right and here after Knight C6 black has
very good compensation but which is what
I was analyzing when I played Queen C7
in fact I was going to play Bishop to E2
to break the pin on the E Pawn right but
uh but instead my opponent quickly
played Queen digs D4 hey this could be
the puzzle of the day except I'm not
playing in the tournament right what's
the winning move for white we'll give
our we'll give our viewers a few seconds
see if a can figure it out I'm guessing
I can I'm assuming it's Queen takes C8
Queen takes C8 yeah and now the is a bit
overloaded that's correct I was hoping
for Knight C6 then I take on
A8 that Queen the queen does just keep
on taking it keeps on yeah yeah my
opponent took on E3 and took on C8 and I
was Queen I was able to win the end game
of piece
up that's more than we can say for some
of our players sorry for sorry about the
chap shot yeah but the truth cannot be
that your Bishop C3 for some reason Luc
is
thinking will he play the novel I notic
that somehow he's yeah I mean his theory
I think with all his Cooling and double
majoring at such a young age yeah I
think that uh he's not really super
keeping on theory of just Theory so
often times he finds himself a little
lost for what's the main
thing yeah but Queen takes his
definitely more sensible than Pon MH and
the other person who sits in this chair
often yes San has had white in this
position many times I'm sure of that yes
he's a proponent of those
positions all right let's go on back to
the R Lopez and instead of Rook E1 he
played
D3 uhhuh so right away he is announcing
that he's not interested in the main
lines although D3 nowadays is kind of a
main line okay and now black is ready to
play once he protected his E Pawn he is
ready to play Knight A5 and get rid of
this menacing Bishop so we are expecting
in either A3 A4 or C3 some move that
will preserve that Bishop right or else
Knight A5 is going to be immediately
equalizing and the and again aot's doing
one of his deep Things Early in the
opening that's
right yeah but this is just normal
position yeah it's a theoretical
position very wellknown position very
popular nowadays because of the ways you
want to when you want to avoid the
Marshall for example or when you just
want to avoid the lines okay you see it
a lot yeah we just play Slowly instead
of playing for D4 we play for D even at
the very highest levels you've seen this
position several times many times if
Arthur can draw his first game of the
event and Jeffrey wins uh his game we'll
have a three-way tie for first Jo into
the last round that'll be really
exciting speaking of
Jeffrey Bishop D3 Knight G2 again
where's the yeser why am I sitting here
another favorite favorite setup both
against the Kings Indian and the
bonon yeah
I like when Yer plays Knight G3 and his
opponent plays H5 H4 and he plays Knight
H1
yeah I like playing moves like Knight H1
Knight h8 so I'm a
fan it's unusual confusing the opponent
mhm all right we're still in theory we
can go on a little
bit and again we have an interesting
move Queen
C7
I'll take white yeah I'm not exactly
sure what the rush was to return with
the queen so fast but okay yeah never
seen taking in G6 and queen C7 it just
seems very passive for black
right it's look like a pos position that
that can happen um in the modern filor
even yeah like E4 E5 lines and uh where
black plays after Knight F3 D6 and after
D4 captures captures and uh yeah this
position could happen in that opening as
well
for some reason black lost the tempo
with Queen A5 to C7 that's right many
times the queen and the Fadel just go to
C7 in one move so I'm not exactly I'm
not excited about the way why black
handled this position it almost looks
like a really good fador I like White's
development I like white space Advantage
I really like his Center and he hasn't
committed yet where he's going to Castle
although I'm nearly sure he's going to
Castle kingside castling Queen side is
going to invite a really quick Pawn
storm
so yeah nice position for white Black's
pretty passive we like
white and after Knight d11 he is in the
think tank yeah maybe now he says wait a
minute that's not the way it was
supposed to happen normally when that
happens my knight on D4 can take
something and now it cannot so yeah he's
going to try to figure out what to do my
guess is that he's going to play
something like he could still play in
the spirit of the opening and after C3
just go to C6 but then he's going to
have to reckon with a very quick
D4 H really don't like the way black
played
it all right we'll see what he
chooses and need to take with the queen
castles and I'm having dja Vu here you
guarantee the game will go the same way
rookie all the way to the end all the
way till resigns
yeah yeah E3 is a little more flexible
than Knight F3 so sometimes we play
Knight E2 Play Bishop D3 Knight E2 the
Knight can go to F4 yeah again we're
touching a subject that we discussed uh
several times in the tournament and I
think it's really good for our younger
viewers who are watching when you have a
flexible move that you know you're going
to make namely Pawn E2 E3 to that Bishop
F1 can see the light of day then play
that first the Knight on on G1 can go to
F3 maybe it's going to end up there but
maybe under the right circumstances he
going to you have a bishop on D3 Knight
E2 and then maybe you have some hopes of
maybe even advancing in the center right
with F3 and E4 yeah yeah that happens in
many Nimo Nimo
Indians so still Theory and L is back
thinking it looks a little disinterested
he's like looking away from the board
yeah again this isn't a Luke's High
position where there's fire on the board
yeah he's not uh not getting his
positions in this tournament not even
once we've been talking to him again and
again about it and he's semi- apologetic
but of course it's not his fault it's he
needs some
cooperation yeah now he's playing more
like me yeah solid and boring 001
advantage that's what I want he's
playing like the luk of 20 years from
now right mhm exactly okay down the list
we go up the list or up the list yeah
okay so after D6 white doing it again
yeah he's not sure he doesn't know what
maybe he's choosing a plan maybe he just
knows doesn't know what to do he played
A3 he played A3 okay very
normal one of the one of the moves that
are
possible and we expect arur to
Castle
y this is going to be a slow positional
maneuvering game which uh we've been
seeing a lot of in the junior mhm Well
author has several choices I mean Bishop
E6 is always interesting in positions
like
this but yeah most flexible castles and
he castled
yeah and he played Knight
C3
mhm you the one time I I had white uh
and a Lopez like this kind of variation
I played C3 and A4 and Knight bd2 and
the game never ended and eventually I
won yeah but he immediately played
Knight to B8
mhm so he wants to play the Brier
without white ever playing D4 mhm
he's going to put his Knight back on D7
put the bishop on
B7 yeah A3 Knight C3 very slow it looked
more like a Four Knights but now now
we're gonna get back into R Lopez ter
it's going be again expected a long
maneuver in
game
yeah I was hoping for a marshall so I'm
a bit disappointed
but I can't say that I really believe
that the Marshall would
occur right so next game and the Wonders
played E6 get back into the B
B white castled we're expecting a
capture on
D5 then we can make side bets about
which way white will recapture that's
right I'm guessing that after Ed he's
going to take CD yeah it's a Junior
tournament
yeah yeah Jeffrey would want to do that
so yeah we'll wait and
see is there another move that's not e
is's there a waiting move um there's A6
yeah you could play A6 I guess I could
play Knight
A6 yeah I played this line with white
against Bon but I play Knight F3 and H3
and play Knight E2 my Bishop's on D3 and
I've taken back both ways on D5 just not
at the same
time but yeah I'm less familiar
personally with with Bishop D3 Knight E2
uhhuh Jeffrey is pretty happy no hoodie
yet well since there's no Knight F3 and
there's no no chance to pin the Knight
we have Bishop G4 like we used to they
usually do in the Bon I'm assuming that
black pun is going to be Knight A6 C7
and after the inevitable capture on D5
maybe even immediately play B6 and maybe
bishop
A6 some plan that involves trying to get
rid of that annoying Bishop on D3 and
solving the bishop the the Eternal
weakness of the bishop on C8 since the
players are slowing down now I'd like to
have a talk about what we expected
before the tournament and what we're
seeing now yeah so I just want to say
some things that to
me I wouldn't have expected um one is
that uh Jeffrey Jang has five draws yes
you told me that before the tournament
after seven
rounds I would somebody could have won a
big bet no he's half a point out of
first which is very reasonable but five
draws is a lot of for Jeffrey in this
field he's the highest rated player
that's right um akad Chandra had three
and a half out of four and then he's
been sort of Lucky to draw every game I
mean he played started out playing great
and then just sort of like oh I was
lucky I drew that game I was lucky I
drew that game thinking a lot in the
opening wow yeah I mean he could have a
lot less points than he has now surely
uh if you told me Arthur Shen had five
wins and two losses I wouldn't have
believed that right Wonder leang had two
and a half out of three and then just
totally faltered MH now I'm not
surprised to wonder has three and a half
out of seven that's probably what I
would befor but two and a half out of
three was a shocking start for him and
um yeah Luke Harman vatti has not had
the kind of positions that he likes we
have memories of him playing really
exciting games in previous Juniors and
somehow couldn't yeah he's like we're
sure he's going to lose and he wins or
draws and yeah this has been not the
most exciting um I didn't really know a
lot about Curran Han or mik you know
Bratton but M has a lot of draws five
draws and two losses right and um a on
Leo I wouldn't have expected to be
playing so well the first 25 moves and
then not having the good technique right
so it's been a pretty surprising Junior
and that and we have really bunched up
field the top three and we're still not
sure who's going to win but yeah the the
way the games have gone have been a bit
surprising yeah I agree I agree with
much most of what you said yeah indeed
five five draws for Jeffrey sh if he has
five draws and two wins he would have
been vice versa he would have been more
expected right yeah if I ask you after
seven rounds Jeffrey has five of
something obviously it won't be losses
so you ask you wins or draws you would
say in an instance wins for sure yeah
but he's been playing very very safe chz
uh doesn't take many risks trying to
play uh to just outplay the opponent
kind of grind a grind down as opposed to
a fleshy style and here it didn't work
out too well I mean it's funny that the
game that he won too a few rounds ago he
could was a piece up and he almost Drew
that's right I mean yeah he was a bit uh
how should I say uh unctious against his
opponent I took the wrong Pawn with a
knight and uh yeah it could have been a
draw it could have easily been a draw
and yesterday however he gave a half a
point away uh so we could have be
talking about him having three wins and
four draws we could be talking about
Chandra having three and a half out of
four then three and a half out of seven
that's right that could have been the
case as well vsha drew his last three
games but we know already that typical
of strong players is uh the ability to
uh withstand the one unsurprising
statistic if you would ask me before the
tournament that which two players don't
have any losses can we pick the right
two chandre and Jong don't have any
losses so yeah that's that that's the
least surprising right item yeah well I
guess what have more surprises the next
two rounds could be yeah I'm really
excited to see how the Chandra uh shen
game is going to
develop and a Wonder did trade on D5 and
as expected C takes D both captures are
expect are possible but he took CD yeah
and after Knight B8 uh once again
Shandra is having one of his long
things yeah we were expecting Sicilian
after E4 not that we were expecting E4
but right I think I was expecting D4 to
but when he played E4 maybe he prepared
some specific line right Arthur might
have smelled the rat well in advance
thanks to his brother Victor and the
secret file the secret files exactly and
prepared some E4 E5 maybe he saw that
Chandra is when he plays E4 against E5
he doesn't doesn't have very venomous uh
variations and well if to judge in after
this position it's not not wrong right
yeah A3 and 9c3 is
not not the most scary lines in the
Royal offense there are some lines in
the Royal off in the main lines that
black really has to be accurate and know
what he's doing here it seems very very
UNS it's funny if white plays D4 and
then black plays Knight bd7 it's like a
filor where Black's played A6 B5 and
white played Bishop C4 to B3 and both
sides have lost a million temp that's
right and people that play the F don't
know that when the bishop is on C4 and
black has an attempt to play the move B5
white almost automatically plays A4 to
stop it so only black can be happy about
uh this also playing D3 and then
D4 yeah
okay so we are still expecting move from
Chandra we'll go to our next game we
said we really really like white yeah G4
and yeah those youngsters they're not
waiting for anything G's happy Matt
larsson's happy everybody's happy yeah
we've seen a lot of E4 F4 G4 this
tournament well this is the game I Prett
would be a draw uh
oh well listen it's not out of the
question yet yeah yeah but I really like
white I like the move G4 here really I'm
just curious what what does he intend to
do with his
King you you and you and your king yeah
so if I'm castling now as black with the
idea of Rook E8 and
uh then what are you going to play Queen
F3 and then and long Castle hooray a
long Castle maybe you can yeah then I
can play F5 G5 I don't know with the
bishop on G7 and the chance to play B5
is a bit a bit alarming but uh only a
bit yeah especially if I'm predicting a
draw that's not good yeah I think this
prediction is already thrown to the
basket
yeah so look over here in ruang Lee's
game yeah what happen there we see a
double fiing kto after Knight D1 B6
uhhuh and then Bishop
B7
uh-huh not sure if I like the double F
when white plays
D4
no I I'm clearly voting for white in
this game and he castled
yep so black basically gave up on the
plan of advancing his B Pawn uh to B5
and
B4 now let's see white I I really like
white I really really like white I think
that white is quite content here I can
see him playing D4 I can see him playing
F4 yeah and black doesn't have the
Queens side counter play or the Knight
D4 mhm white doesn't even have to bother
to play D4 can just continue with his SP
on the king side yeah if he plays F4 KN
his Knight has the F2 square and later
G4 yeah that's right that's
right I can Envision the Knight on F2
with G4 G5 Knight G4 and he has like all
these pieces ready made for an
attack I prefer
white and he played Knight E7 as
expected now it's the Moment of Truth F4
D4 or Bishop H6 right got to pick one of
them I have to say that Bishop H6 is
possible just for the sake of trading
Bishops obviously but the normal idea of
Bishop H6 Castle H4 H5 is no longer
possible because the Rook has left H1
white has Castle so he may still play
Bishop H6 for the sake of trading
instantly so it could be something like
Bishop H6 castles takes G7 followed by
F4 yeah now the Knight on D1 has the E3
Square now that the bishop even better
yes so that's that will be a semi-normal
position M uh black is going to try to
play for D5 in that
position
yeah of course another option is to just
go
D4 and black is going to have to decide
what he wants to do he might take take
and D5 that's also a possibility very
exciting
position and rrang answered quite
quickly play yeah yeah I would be taking
my time here because I would know which
plan to do I'm assuming you went Bishop
A6 Play Bishop A6 and he castled quickly
C
right rof Fang Lee playing so quickly
could it be prepped yeah it's really
quick he took
immediately the moves are fast G7 as
expected King takes yeah and let's talk
a little bit about our
Wild Card the winner of the US Junior
open Kiran Han and uh yeah he started
the tournament on the left foot with two
quick losses and since then you can say
that he definitely showed that he can
play some CH he overcame his uh his
Jitters and his fear maybe or whatever
he uh he had against the higher rated
players and now he's playing with very
very little very little inferiority
feelings yeah right in the last several
games yeah I mean against Arthur he
missed uh
yesterday
also who did he play Yesterday yeah
yesterday he had a ear good position
against was it was it Mika or was itan
Leo was Leo exactly that's the gift
thatan got yep yeah I mean a really nice
position he played a beautiful
combination um with Knight D7 Rook moves
Rook takes C6 and The Rook was immune
because of the M threats on the back
ring he had an extra Pawn Plus the
initiative um it was hard to see the the
move the computer judg is the best move
Rook A6 back there but if he would have
just played simply I think that U the
point was his to take okay so not so
easy against much higher rated players
um yeah also his draw against Luke
Harman valti was very convincing almost
you could not tell who the higher rated
player was in that game um wow he moved
again very quickly and what happened did
he play I just saw him hit the clock I
don't even know if he made a move maybe
he just hit the clock maybe Knight E3
what did he play y Knight E3 Knight E3
Now The Bishop's not on E3
MH not curious what he's going to do
against oh I guess the Knight could be
heading to G4 and queen H6 yeah this
could become yeah this could become
exciting
yeah I like reminds me of Knight G4 I
was thinking black could play Knight G8
here and uh that reminded me of
yesterday when OA could have played
Knight G8 against Jeffrey strong he said
no that's just like that amounts to
resigning yeah I can't play n
thisposition a little different of
course
yeah I'm always impressed when we
interview young players who are high
rated to see how much despite this the
young age and and if you look at aot's
rating let's say a year or two ago let's
say two years ago he was at best a club
player I think and now already is at the
with two GM norms and it's amazing how
fast they grow and evolve it makes you
want to come back into chess and get
those Norms yes it makes me want to go
back in time and early back in time okay
yeah but why not do it now that's even
more impressive yeah you're not the only
one who's asking I'm not the only one
no but looking at this just it's
inspiring on one hand I'm impressed by
the titles and by their uh amazing
ability on the other hand with you know
with misss and and the yeah technique to
be designed you have the feeling hey I
can do that too now you've played in the
US chess League maybe at least once or
at most once that's the least memorable
of my life I don't think I won a game in
that event yeah yeah but I must say that
you know it's also a question of uh
personal preference for me to sit
without an opponent and a computer
something uninspiring about it it's much
more exciting to play a real opponent
see their faces see how they feel yeah
Patrick Wolf hasn't played in
tournaments like probably since you and
uh he played in the US chess league and
he I think so but he he didn't make him
want to play in tournaments
[Music]
right very busy or's playing in US chess
League also who's that orov yes another
strong player yeah yeah Washington the
state I am and the coach a local Coach
obviously should be a GM and also serper
also from Washington Grandmaster a nice
shout out to our friend uh Greg serper
who I've seen at the castle chest camp
in Atlanta just some weeks ago yeah it
was nice after I 10 or 15 years hias we
used to coach at the same chess Camp uh
in the in Wisconsin Back in the Day wish
I remember wish chess exactly so it was
a great reunion and we have corresponded
since and just a wonderful person and a
very strong sh yeah I want to give a
shout out to the night relocation camp
in in Michigan I teach there every year
in Arbor but obviously I'm here now
that's right so um I recommended
Alexander shabalov I guess who's
teaching there now uh Alexander shabalov
yeah and there should be on the air
listening right yeah they're listening
now and they're taking some of these
positions from our games and showing the
students and right trying to see if you
know their students can get on get on
this program and sit between us in a few
years that'll be very nice and explain
their moves to us and they have chosen
wisely your advice was good mhm you know
chess Hol Famer yeah Grand Master very
original player Alexander
chaalo excellent choice okay now in this
game we saw a lot of moves but nobody
hung all their pawns like in my game so
Knight F3 was played instead of e3 okay
C6 E3 anyways Rook E8 Bishop D3 Bop F5
yep and White's thinking and this game
is going to produce fireworks like in
Mikel Tal's games right exactly or not
like like the fireworks and meow's games
games today that's the same number of
fireworks
yeah yeah it's funny uh the first time I
ever saw tall like in in person 1988 I
went to the World Chess Festival in St
John New Brunswick Canada what was it
called there and uh I walked into a
skittles room and there were two guys
playing Blitz chess and they were
surrounded by infinite number of people
and I you know looked in and it was tall
was white against Alon o Zapata and the
Colombian Grand Master who now lives in
Atlanta I guess right yes and uh tall
was down a queen and he had a knight on
D6 as compensation really strong Knight
and black couldn't move because the
Knight was so strong and and tall one I
didn't see him sack the queen but I was
like the first game I ever to see tall
play as a Blitz game where he sacked his
Queen for positional compensation and he
won yeah so that was a real impressive
to me he won the world Blitz
Championship that year ahead of Kasparov
and karpov that's right $50,000 first
yeah a lot of money back in the day
still yeah nowaday then but then even
even more yeah I remember the first time
I met Talent person I was actually
introduced to him by Grandmaster Demitri
gurovich from Chicago I was in Vegas and
they were talking and I was there he
introduced me and mik tal is known as
one of the most gracious players ever
despite being a world champion and one
of the best of all time he had very
small ego not really very very modest I
remember they were analyzing some bra in
the Sicilian and he was sitting next by
and they were talking all the Grand
Master were contributing he was saying
nothing then somebody decided to ask the
great Misha for his opinion and then he
started talking and as he was talking
everybody else got quiet everybody
including The Grandmaster Grandmasters
got a a lesson on the Shing and sicilan
he explained the nuances and it was just
it was beautiful it was definitely a
memorable moment yeah he was a real
amazing player
definitely and he played the New York
open once I think
1990 I think he took TX second place
after was it kamsky who won it somebody
won it no no not kamsky somebody else or
maybe maybe
kamsky so yeah this game is not going to
produce lots of fireworks Let's uh
quickly go very tall like
no let's go back he and he played Knight
E2 okay very similar to the maneuver
Rook E1 Knight D2 Knight F1 Knight G3
right the Knight going to get to G3
eventually yeah greener pastur on the
king
side and uh you know somewhat normal
yeah White's going to try to attack on
the king side yeah and the reason
they're thinking in this position is um
I think both players are thinking about
the move order because the plans are
pretty clear but you want to make sure
that you choose the proper move sometime
you can get into into trouble for
example I can tell you that U one of my
students was actually another Roy Lopez
um played something very innocently but
seems like logical so let's pretend
we'll use it apply it to this position
something like let's say Knight bd7
Knight G3
Rook E8 with the intention of playing
bishop f8 and all of a sudden
comes Bishop takes F7 King takes Knight
G5 and Knight E6 so yeah I mean this is
of course after Bishop F7 the king had
to move Bishop took the rook and
exchange an a pawn up white had no
problem winning the game so yeah you
want to be a bit cautious about
accidents like this and also think to
yourself what is what is the right move
order should should he play Rook E8
leave the bishop on C8 play Rook E8
Bishop f8 G6 quickly so as to neutralize
the F5 Square from the Knight or choose
another move order maybe Knight D7
Knight C5 hit the bishop with a Tempo
and exposed the bishop on C8 uh to the
F5 square like it is now many many
different nuances and we'll see which
one ARA chooses to me it seems like uh
Rook E8 Knight G3
G6 is not unreasonable like I said
another plan when the bishop cannot
change diagonals and go to C2 is to play
Bishop E6 yeah that's what challenging
just go for it you're going to either
trade the Bishops or Force white to play
C4 which is that's right and C4 is
really not the move in that position
especially since I can just take it less
explosive than usual yeah I'm just going
to take it and if you take with a pawn
E4 goes so yeah so Arthur's thinking
about all that stuff because I think
this position is unfamiliar to both
players and us too that's right order is
very unusual yeah they just want to make
sure that they're Sid stepping any
landmines on route to uh you know full
development all right so this is our
exciting game of the day and it's
developing to a maneuvering game but
still full body Anything Can
Happen yeah let's go further yeah and
you were thinking o Wonder might play
the Knight A6 idea and he did right B6
KN A6 yeah this is this is very standed
because if you play A6 and then A4 then
it's going to be awfully hard to play
the move B5 right so here now the idea
is again Knight D7 Bishop A6 and uh no
the I can even go to B4 now cuz white
played a early right that is exactly
right that's another another possibility
B4 has been
weakened so again a typical but only
like ideas and
structures nothing new Under the Sun I
would
say I'm actually surprised Jeffrey
played A4 so quickly when B5 wasn't
that's right what was the rush right
right yeah he could have waited
for yeah especially when you play B6
there's no rush to play A4 maybe he's
intending to play A5 himself yeah or he
was thinking after Bishop a six he could
block on
B5 yeah but yeah this okay it's a bonon
and it's it's more interesting than I I
thought we're going to see a slow
positional maneuvering game which which
we might see but in a bonon here you
have lots of tactics and tricks and
blackish gton is gonna have to release
his position somehow I think it's the
first Bon of the tournament it is we've
had nimos we've had Slavs G grinfeld
even some Kings Indian but this is and
black castled after G4 which you
expected
in the game between Yan Leo and M
Bratton and I'm thinking White's going
to quickly play F5 G5 if
possible and maybe he'll Castle Queen
side
first I don't know my instinctive move
in the Blitz game is Queen F3 but
right somehow I don't know G5 Knight H5
might give me pause because the
opportunity of Knight g3 at some moment
so like there's no Bishop E2 because
Knight yeah I was thinking of playing F5
first so I can could play G5 F6 although
after F5 I'm giving E5 away so the Black
Knight can go to E5
yeah very interesting double-edged
position much more exciting than I was
expecting from this game that's right I
mean optically looking those pawns on EF
and G4 are exciting he just played Queen
F3 okay that makes sense yeah but it
looks to me like you cannot just send
the pawns on attack with the queen back
on D1 the Rooks are connected your king
is in the center with an open E file I
mean I would love to do it but let's be
reasonable now the big question is is he
going to go left with the king is he
going to go right is he going to still
leave it in the center for a bit well at
the St Louis chess club The Way We
handle these positions is we play King
to D2 We have seen this is how we handle
it here yes as a matter of fact just
before the game Alex Mar told me about
the some positions again the player will
remain nameless to protect the innocent
exactly where um it was a dilemma what
he should Castle what he should do and
he solved that problem with playing King
D2 because before that he saw a lecture
saying that the king is an active piece
yeah but I guess he yawned at the part
when somebody said in the end
game exactly that that little caveat he
uh he forgot about so yeah I'm expecting
a move like Rook E8 that move kind of
begs to be played and uh then we'll see
what what white wants to do how long is
he going to be able to leave his King in
the center for I don't think
forever no I'm hoping for Queen side
castling and we'll see lots of
excitement yes me too although I have to
tell you even after King set casting and
the King goes to the side
still there could still be a lot of
action
still but I think the black needs to to
move
it yeah not just let white yeah there's
got to be a B5 in the offing
sometime you got to play whatever it
doesn't matter what White Castles I
think B5 and sometimes B4 is something
we need to see especially with Rook E8
try to create pressure against the E
Pawn not so easy I really I'm not crazy
about the tempo that black lost with
Queen A5 Queen C7 can you imagine if if
the pawn was on B5 it would have been
black to move and that would have been a
little more
uh typical to the
position so while we're waiting let's go
on with other
games uhhuh not the most exciting so
they have traded Bishops on F5 yep Queen
after Queen B4 attacking B7 black does
not want to move his pawns and weaken
his structure especially not touch the B
Pawn and make the C Pawn look funny he
just went Queen to
C8 no
l okay I'm voting this game to be a
guaranteed draw guaranteed draw yeah
save for a a real blunder I don't think
there's going to be an out playing I'm
wining my only caveat is there one side
blunders just outright somebody playing
the other I don't see it and I strangely
predicted this game would be be a draw
the one that's with the two Wild players
that's right yeah okay and then we have
our other game where current Han played
Queen to
D7 okay so it's fair to say that he's
planning after Knight G4 to play Knight
G8 I think so that has to be the
plan so I'm looking at this position
remembering black played an early Knight
D4 which we s we thought was Ill time M
and looking now at the
position I'm not seeing how I took
advantage of
it I'm not sure how he could have done
better but uh yeah trading pieces might
not have been the most active way to
that's right take advantage of the
position now I have another Rule and
this is generally for my weaker students
most of my rules are for my Advanced
students uhuh but basically every game
that my students show me when they're
like under 1800 they try to play bishop
and queen and trade the bishop they do
it every game with both colors right say
you're not allowed to do that you just
don't permit it no because I want them
to play chess I want them to play in the
center and castle and get their pieces
out and they're like wait wait I want to
play Bishop E3 Queen D2 B and trade
Bishops and I'm like you want to waste
three time to trade Bishops that's your
goal yeah I can tell you about some of
your students that do worse yeah they
put the queen in front of the bishop and
try to get checkmate in every game yeah
and we know how that how well that works
usually
yeah so I'm curious if there's a move d4
here with the idea of Pawn takes D4 and
then Knight takes D4 is that anything
that of course black can just choose to
hold the position right Bishop takes D4
Knight D4 Bishop D yeah exactly yeah
that's a personal joke nobody will
understand including
us yeah I mean if this happens then I'm
a bit worried about the black d Pawn
because D1 is coming yeah exactly and
yeah so if he doesn't do it then he has
to relinquish his idea of D5 because the
C5 Pawn needs some babysitting there's
no reason for why not to do this this
looks that's right but what I mean is if
you go back to moves black instead of
taking he can just maintain so let's say
he plays Rook d8 in this position one of
the Rooks yeah let's say this one and
there are close Sicilians where black
just holds once D4 is in he play I'm I'm
worried about D5 because my knight seems
like it's trapped on A5 or
E5 I
see ah so in this position maybe yeah
maybe this this move now Queen D7 is
making difficult to do anything well so
now I'm really starting to like wh's D4
maybe it's not so easy to just hold here
because the KN on E7 took the place of
the other Knight
H and I think he played D4 he did really
yep well it's the most sensible I'm
assuming that the intention is if Pawn
take to take with a KN I don't want to
take with the pawn and then D5 yeah
should be okay and then after E5 Knight
F5 or something or not even just holding
its and of course I like that for white
too because Knight G4 is coming I like I
like taking with the pawn and playing E5
also yeah even that is good yeah I like
it with Knight G4 to follow yeah
yeah but black can probably play Knight
F5 and be okay there after Knight
G4 everything looks a little bit better
for
white yeah so we give a slight n for
white here especially after his
expansion move
d4 boy the games are very slow and
methodical today that's right there's no
big fireworks in the opening yet and the
only game everybody's very cautious yeah
I think in uh yeah
the Michael Bratton game where or M
Bratton where W and castle queenside and
everybody goes crazy that's our that's
the one game that's for coffee house
yeah yeah right is that like crazy House
Coffee House yeah close you know
Thursday when I'm resident GM again I
think I'm going to be asked that
question the difference between coffee
what's the differ between Coffee House
and crazy house now there's a good
question that's right yeah now if that's
the only challenging question you ask
you'll be
happy I still have to figure out why
there's eight points on the board but
I'm going to do it
someday some of you students I've heard
U the people that come to your lectures
I've heard that they have books that uh
do not contain some of the things that
you say it's possible sometime you have
to decipher what you mean yeah expend on
their it happens on this show too
yeah exciting
stuff so we want to mention that in
about uh 15 minutes or so we're going to
have our first guest in the studio I
hope it's my come and it's going to be
yes the assistant tournament director
all right uh we put him in the hot seat
here he's going to be in the hot seat
once again he's going to tell us a
little bit maybe we ask him a little
more about uh how the tournament is
going now that it's already and ask him
about the Home Run Derby of course
yesterday and what the Home Run Derby
rep before the allstar game he's very
interested in that also okay more than
me for sure I didn't even know about
that and uh he's going to tell us a
little bit about today's activity in his
lecture where he's going to host Kuran
Hanan uh from this there's going to be a
match up between kran Han and Mike CER
tonight but we're not sure exactly what
they're doing exactly I don't think it's
going to be chess but we'll see I also
don't think that Mike is going to Ral
too much but it's not going to be arm
wrestling either at least he's going to
give us some insight and uh a viewers
can later watch either live or a
recording of that uh oh yeah we're gonna
tape it for sure yes give Ben Simon more
to do that's
right okay so let's jump to the next
game please it's just a jump to the see
what's going
here okay so he chose Knight bd7 Knight
G3 Bishop B7 yeah okay so he's allowing
Knight
F5 I'm slightly puzzled by that I did
not think that he is going to allow
it yeah it seems like white should have
a nice position there yeah yeah what
happens if I play Knight F5 what's wrong
with it I'll play Knight F5 yeah
although I won't call it Knight F5
obviously you call it knife F5 knife to
F5 right a favorite of maafi because it
has knife in it that's right yeah
no this looks really nice for
white it's funny when you get these
positions neither players is familiar
with because they're trying to trick
their opponent I was playing um a good
guy onall in at the spice cup and I
played E4 on move one which I don't
usually play and he immediately played
Knight F6 which he's never played I
was I played a very strange line and
then we both just thought Forever on
every move and eventually agreed to a
draw but you see that both players are
trying to avoid each other's prepar
ation and Nei one knows what they're
doing so yeah nowadays with so many
games of every player in the database um
people think of creative way to sidestep
either an expertise in a certain opening
or a dis liament that you have in a
certain variation or or a hole that you
haven't figure out in another variation
andtime the best way to do it is just to
play something yeah and if Arthur Shen's
usually playing the night ORF then
Knight C3 and A3 in the R Lopez wasn't
number one in his uh that's right in in
his dossier that's right that wasn't in
Victor's file
yeah all right let's see yeah I think
he'll play Knight F5 yeah I mean it
makes sense to play it I think it's just
a normal move here and he played Rook E1
he showed us okay now pretending that he
play Knight D2 to F1 just to show us
well I'm guessing that in this specific
position with a knight on D7 Bishop B7
it's not going to be so easy to play G6
here because after Bishop H6 Rook E8
Knight G5 maybe and can this cause a
little discomfort there I know there's
D5 but then the E5 Pawn looks loose and
no this is going to be good for white
yeah this looks this looks messy for the
wrong reasons for
black so maybe white is in no hurry to
play yeah normally when we play G6 we
preface it with Rook e a bishop f8 first
that's right if that's possible here
again we have your tricks MH looks like
now we can do it now we can do because
the bishop moved from C8 so the queen is
not going to be trapped after a bishop
sacrific so maybe Arthur will play Rook
e a bishop f8 then G6
yeah here's one hope that I'm really
really praying will not happen Rook E8
Knight G5 Rook F Knight F no I don't
think AA wants to do that I don't think
so either
yeah draw that'll be terrible we can't
have any draws yeah it will be tragic on
on many
fronts all right let's see the benon
game what does that have for
us ahuh so he decided to play the move
Bishop to F4 so Knight G3 Knight C7
Bishop
F4
mhm okay now we're expecting potentially
Bishop
A6 yeah and I wonder if White's going to
play Knight B5 and that's why he played
A4 very
possible I'm just trying do something on
B5 yeah again I don't think either
player is necessarily too familiar with
this position don't have a lot of games
in this line always trying to out
prepare the opponent and everybody gets
an unfamiliar territory and they start
thinking a long time in the opening
right happens to me all the
time man when I played matosian in the
first round of the norm tournament last
year
MH I usually don't take an hour of the
first 10 moves I think I took an hour of
the first seven moves really six what
was the opening what well it was E4 C5
and I was trying to avoid the night ORF
and I was playing like an early Knight
C3 and D three somehow I played I played
Bishop E2 yeah I played Bishop E2 and
then I played Bishop C4 like the next
move why didn't you go usual D4 yeah
exactly you're worried about the kings
in he he would have expected that yeah
well I play E4 to surprise yeah yeah I
surprised everybody me him everybody was
the the Arbiters they thought the dgt
was off why is the point on e4 when I
play in the US chess League which is
rare now because for some reason the
people who run the chess club here I
think the Webster kids are better than
me
yeah anyway on the rare occasions I do
play they're like dude just play D4 play
what you know how to play don't be
playing E4 is that the instru oh yeah
don't feel so of course I play E4 B3 I
have I played B3 against the 2200 last
year and I lost and you lost yeah back
to
D4 they're like you can play one C year
but you have to play D4 even when I was
black amazing so it was tough yeah I
don't know why they think the Webster
kids are better than me why do they
think that because the ratings are 150
points higher yeah maybe something to do
okay maybe yeah something to do with 25
years
younger been grand Masters longer than
me even though I'm 25 years older than
them
yeah so if
I okay so I think with the games at
somewhat of a standstill yeah this is
always a good time for us to take a uh
short break we are going to be back
promising a lot more some of the games
are developing to be more exciting than
the others I think that most games are
still uh full of Venom please be back
stay with us or be back with us uh
within the next few minutes for Ben fle
this is every Freedman waiting for you
be right back Mr Mai what's your
favorite part about this
sport I think the strategy how much do
you hate to lose I don't like it at all
what about being second guest I don't
like that either well if I were you I
wouldn't have moved that Rook
Checkmate sorry whether you've played
chess for years or never before come
experience all the sport has to offer at
the world-renowned chess club and
Scholastics Center of St
Louis
[Music]
for
he
[Music]
yeah
know
and we have returned with round eight
coverage of the 2015 US Junior close
Chess Championship coming to you live
from the beautiful chess club and
Scholastic Center of St Louis in
Missouri I'm uh with the local
Grandmaster legendary Ben fold I'm a V
fredman and as you can see we are joined
in the studio by our very competent
uhour let me let me announce Mike come
here there you go in the studio proper
deral Sergeant Announcement by Ben we
have Mike hmer assistant tournament
director and a longtime employee loyal
employee of the club and we are here to
ask him he was here already in the
studio earlier this week we're here to
ask him several questions uh let's start
with uh how is the tournament
progressing from your point of you is it
becoming easier with every day that
passes or how is the winding going tell
us a little bit Yeah the the winding is
going a lot better we had one uh HIC up
uh with ma he had uh snuck in some uh
gum uh one day
wow did you have to give a piece to
everybody is that the rule you said
Paran not cont that's that's that's the
feed rule you have to give a piece to
everybody two to Tony and two to Mike
you saw Blazing Saddles should bring
enough for everybody then otherwise
exactly and uh yeah I think that uh
looking at this beautiful group of
players who are really good sports uh
Sportsmen and uh I think you're you're
not very busy right there aren't that
many issues no forfeits no well I heard
you guys give me some Flack about what
took so long on declaring the uh the uh
three-fold repetition in the uh as shock
game well first because it was a was
before 30 moves right I had to actually
go back and verify I know they both
wanted a draw but you know if they
didn't you know do it correctly then
because it wasn't 30 moves I had to
actually verify that it was three full
repetition make sure there's no
Shenanigans going on so that's why it
took me you know too long minutes you
know to figure out that ruling
absolutely and I wanted you to know that
every flag that you get is coming from
Ben I'm only giving you compliments yeah
of course he never gotten flaged from me
before he shock never ever yeah it's a
yeah it's a surprise for you so I know
that you're also here to tell us about
the special event that's taking place
tonight and uh well I actually without
too much introduction I will leave the
whole presentation to you please sure
thing okay so as you may or may not know
I teach uh a class on the YouTube
channel uh beginner breakdown down who
doesn't know that come on who doesn't
yes beginner beat down yeah beat down it
might be changing so so for the uh
seventh year anniversary last year we
had a special where I uh did my best
Clinton Eastwood impersonation and uh
reenacted the uh the uh RNC uh chair gag
and uh that was a lot of fun you could
look that up on uh YouTube anyhow so
this year you can just have me like
Clint Eastwood uh chair parody or
something but anyway so this year I I
I'm going to do something very special
this year uh none other than uh National
Master Karan rayan will be in the hot
seat all right initially I was just
going to analyze his uh his games
against uh you know a Wonder talking
about hey why you playing the uh the
back roow defense and everything and
then uh and then his game against uh
bodok where he had one piece off the
back roow the uh dark Square bishop and
he did everything he could to trade it
so so I was just going to you know kind
of kind of joke around with him on that
one but instead I'm just going to go for
the glory and uh I'm going to put down
$50 of my own hard-earned money very
harder hard even hard to open the
envelope 50 singles 50 bucks and uh are
you we're going to play a very special
exhibition match now wait are you the
kind of guy who pays your parking fines
and pennies that's what it looks like
yeah yeah so if he beats me oh he's a
kid like they like $1 I like the way you
got $1 bills in an ATM envelope that
must that must have been tough to do
okay but let's not spoil the story call
with a story what tell us exactly the
details or you're allowed to tell I
can't expose all the details because I
don't want to give him any kind of
Advantage I want to shock him with a
surprise because you know he has uh
rated about 400 points higher than me so
so he's got an advantage there but I
have advantages with uh my surprise and
uh some very special St home court
advantage yes and a cheering section
that's right that's right the class
loyal the loyal classmates yes okay so
that will take place tell us when where
yes 6:30 uh probably in the uh
tournament Hall uhhuh upstairs in the uh
so if you are local if you are in the
area then we strongly recommend uh for
you to attend the class with that
special feature today it's always nice
to see a local Chessmaster a not local a
guest chess master uh being challenged
to some sort of a mystery match yes by
one of the locals and if the games are
still going on we're going to stop them
so mycer can
doj we might even have Kuran Han seal a
move just so you can yeah but I
think exactly already have the envelope
ready and for those of us who those of
the viewers who are not as fortunate and
geographically challenged and cannot
come to the club will they see a
recording of that well hopefully our uh
very very uh great uh producer van Simon
can expedite this to get up there uh as
soon as possible and he will take care
of the
videotaping uh yes and hopefully the uh
ring introductions as well yes he does
very well with the wrestling yeah we
should mention to those who don't know
that on his spare time is the second uh
hobby vocation Mr Simon our producer who
was already uh on in the studio several
days ago he uh doubles as a ring
announcer in wrestling matches yes I've
actually I've attended one of them for
the $2 beers obviously but at the South
partway Athletico and it was a lot of
fun it was it was great because of Ben
Simon or for other
reasons yeah two do beers you can't beat
it okay so is he a good announcer it's
fantastic you know he's just he's he's
in there he's like down goost Frasier
yes it's like it's pretty good okay very
good so we're GNA be we hoping to see uh
a combination of him playing wearing two
hats as both the announcer and the uh
video videographer well well Jonathan's
doing such a great job of videotaping he
might just he might just leave that to
him ah so we might have two of our
staffers uh join you on this more the
May exactly I know I'll be there
definitely definitely no kitzing no
kitzing Mike is already covering all
angles okay so uh if you're a betting
man and I know you are would you say
that you will be separated from your $50
or no what are the odds what is the over
under
I do make a lot of bad bets but this
isn't really a bet i' I've successfully
defended my $100 banty against the suer
room and I'm hoping to now is it
possible to lose partial that you lose
50 or lose nothing what are the you can
give that away yeah it's just yeah he's
either going to get 50 or not y okay
okay yeah wow and that's tonight at 6:30
for those who can come to the club and
watch that beginner breakdown Lex your
7th year anniversary special with
national master and us uh junior Open
winner and our Wild Card Kuran Han and
along with Mike kmer The Man Behind the
show I'm guessing if he gets separated
from his $50 it'll be a mik Hummer
breakdown I think the reason he gave it
in singles it's like a mother saying
goodbye to the child on the way to the
to the school just like wanted very slow
very hard separation but well we'll see
you might be able to keep it we might
interview next time with the very same
envelope still in your pocket so we we
wishing that everybody that can make it
tonight make it to the club if you
cannot please subscribe to our beautiful
Channel and be sure to catch it later on
on a video by Jonathan shrz and Ben
Simon from our very own production staff
so Mike before we uh let you go to your
uh busy job anything else you want to
add about the tournament there's any
anecdotes from upstairs we know that one
time one of the players had to take his
shoes off because of the W thing uh yes
asak uh Shandra yes he uh like on day
two you scan it and it was all beeping
and so so so then the next day came in
with a new pair of shoes so sneakers I
didn't want any any more Shenanigans
yeah I guess those are uh two metallic
maybe they were the shoes from get smart
he didn't make a phone call it's the
wizard of us yeah exactly okay Mike
we're going to let you go because we
know we were very busy and thank you
very much for joining us in the studio
once again pleas thank you for all the
work that you do for the club always
appreciate it s and the money goes back
to the envelope and we are going back to
the games and here is Kuran Han facing
us he's already
in concentration mode something that
probably is going to be uh carried over
to the myomer lecture later on 6:30
tonight at
club and we are going to look at the
game between alang and Kuran Hanan since
they are the already in the live picture
mhm and we see that uh some things have
changed yeah it looks like white must
have traded on D4 the pawn uhuh and
let's take a look slightly surp decided
to take with a pawn and then play E5 a
must obviously on H 5 stopping our
Knight G4 forever right because that
Knight was heading not only after Knight
G4 not only is he heading to F6 but also
the queen was heading to H6 I guess much
like AKA Chandra yesterday Knight G8 is
not a popular move among Juniors very
hard move to make and he prefer to do
that Knight F4 I must say that again off
hand the black position looks a little
groggy right isn't it yeah the dark
squares are not so I can't really ever
play Knight F5 cuz when white takes it I
don't I can't really take back that's
right you can lose a pawn either H5 or
D5 that's not pleasant Bishop B7 not the
proudest piece in the uh in the set and
uh you know white has chances of has a
space advantage and can control the dark
squares yeah yeah and at one time he
might even start pushing pawns on the
king side somehow you know G4 is not H4
G4 or some some sort of a line like this
is not out of the
question so we like white yeah we like
white and of course every movie is going
to have to calculate what if there is
going to be some sacri rice you know H5
D5 and crazy stuff
here all right so we like white
mhm next we had a little we had some
stuff here that I I thought white was
doing well yeah after C3 he played
bishop f8 and white played Knight G5 as
mentioned because Arthur Shen can't play
Rook E7 because of Knight F5 that's
right so normally we're playing either
Rook f8 or Rook E7 in these positions
and normal real lope has positions but
let me guess he DED well yeah good guess
what else good yes right yeah takes took
and
uh are we current hold on I have
something to say uh what yeah exactly
what are you gonna do you can't take
back because Queen H5 is just
winning I know you can't play Knight D
Knight Knight D5 Queen H5 the game's
over yeah you can't defend F7 and H7
yeah this is one of the oldest tricks in
the book so if if it's white move I
would assume C4 wins so or D6 yeah so
but how about H6 I'm guessing that's not
only maybe H6 only H6 right it looks
like okay now off the top of my head
with no engine which means I'm going to
get very embarrassed I'm looking at 96
no I'm looking at
96 you have to take it you're down a
pawn I strongly recommend it yes and now
I'm threading E7
check so I I and I have a feeling that
arur I don't I don't like black yeah the
wrong way you hear me talking I don't
like he's going to have to move the king
and lose the horse no I don't like black
here Black's out a pawn and worse that's
right yeah okay again I'm Knight F7 is
possible retreating the knight's Poss I
mean I'm not saying 96 is Forest I just
like 96 and we can see Arthur in the uh
lower right in the upper right and we
can see that he has that face of uh
something went
wrong right because you you after Knight
G5 you always want to play either Rook
f8 or Rook E7 I've never seen a r Lopez
where black play D5 here no in the two
knights maybe that's right I mean okay
it's not completely outrageous but with
the Knight on G5 and the queen heading
to H5 mhm that doesn't look promising no
and you can see he looks really unhappy
and uh all of a sudden that structure
let's say if Knight B6 then C4 can just
be played you know what time it is time
to cheat and how is that with your
computer oh of course he's like wait I
forgot how to cheat it's been so long
I'm so excited by that I'm guessing like
1.4 that's what I'm guessing well no wow
what does it say it says Black's doing
great it says black is doing reasonably
well after Knight C5 but only Knight C5
I didn't see because 86 Knight E6 indeed
you're right Knight B6 C4 of course we
are right again and Knight
C5 Knight C5 looks like it just uh now
he has no time to move the bishop it
just delays so you'd have to play C4 and
then after the trade okay there's going
to be some compensation for the pawn
that for sure after Knight C oh after
Knight C5 Bishop A2 I can play Bishop D5
and myen is defending correct cu the
knight's not on D7 anymore so you'd have
to okay having said you'd have to say B
with C4 after Knight
C5 and uh right and then I'm assuming
that he's going to take on B3 is that
what the computer wants to do let's see
yeah I guess black has some compensation
now although I'll still take white yeah
this idea with Bishop D5 Queen D5 right
but the idea is that he's going to have
an uncontested light Square Bishop so uh
the idea is Knight C5
C4 play those moves please
yep and Knight takes B3 Queen takes C6
so he wants to give a pawn and the idea
is that pawn D3 is going to be backward
D4 belongs to Black the bishop on B7 is
going to shoot on a very nice long
diagonal and Knight G5 is a bit stranded
not so sure probably maybe he can land
on e4 but it's not a stable Square
so
yeah the computer prefers white by a
little bit of course Pawn is a pawn but
it's not just a
pawn it's not just a pawn for nothing
it's like his only chance and he's
having a long think about it that's
right well he kind of enter it
unexpectedly right he did not invite
this night G5 just completely
underestimated it and that's we were
talking about it before right about how
all of a sudden at the wrong time Knight
G5 sometime Bishop F7 can occur probably
if you would have seen it probably Rook
Rook E8 would not have been Bishop f8
would not have been
played he looks like he's just ready to
move but he won't do it
yeah
yeah this is going to be a long thing
it's it's getting hot in there yeah and
I think that this is the best position
Chandra had in four games yeah yeah even
though he's behind on the clock it's
only by eight minutes not by his usual
80 minutes notice that he's not even at
the board very relaxed he realizes that
he's going to be up a pawn uh sure his
opponent is going to have some
compensation but but only if he finds
Knight C5 exactly a lot of trouble yeah
followed by the very brave C6 that pawn
just took one Pawn he's going to take
another yeah
okay let's wait and see what Arthur
plays can we go to our Bon game and I
think that there I'm really favoring
what uh A1 young did he uh played A6 I
think in that position A6 made more
sense right Bishop A6 might have run to
something to B5 like suest now with A6
the point is that um black wants to play
something like Bishop D7 with a B5 I
think I can just play B5 right away I
think I haven't prepared enough uh
that's right of course yeah
The Rook is already on B8 yeah so B5 is
coming and it's always a good expansion
notice that white played Rook B1 so now
I'm pretty certain that on B5 comes
takes takes B4 right trying to blockade
the pawns and uh yeah very normal
occurrence in the Bon and again you have
to make a decision if you take B5 is
under heavy
fire and the question is can you hold
maybe you have to play Knight A6 and B4
or normally I'm playing Knight D4 to C6
here but his Knight already went to G3
that's right
yeah it'll be slightly illegal and uh
again after C4 Bishop C2 yeah white
relinquishes black relinquishes the uh
D4 square and with the weakness on C6
like you said Knight E2 Knight D4 even
if you have to play a move like
F3 reinforcing the E4 uh E4 pawn and
again if you look at Knight C7 where is
he
going right so Rook B1 the idea of
playing B4 at the right moment is is a
good idea mhm and uh that uh gives us
pause as to whether we should play B5
immediately or not that pawn may end up
as a
problem um another idea which is again
not so easy to execute is to try to
overprotect D6 and on B4 get ready to
play Knight D7 so there's a knight
taking on D on
C5 um also not easy to execute yeah I'd
like to play Knight D7 to E5 here but my
opponent on D6 is hanging that's right
so that's not easy nothing's easy in the
bon no no not nothing you know the
famous Bon story uh in the 1983 or 84 us
Championship conran shazi got half out
of 17 not a good score but he didn't
have the worst score with
black really some black he h Drew and
somebody went zero out of eight and it
was Sergey kudrin really and I was like
oh was was kran playing the the drag no
no back then kudan didn't didn't play
the G Bon yeah and got got zero lot of
zeros yeah Bon is tough yeah well I mean
many American players used to play the
Bon because they played in open
tournament you got to win games exactly
when you play two rounds a day you
cannot afford to win with white draw
with black that's going to keep you out
of the money and with no rent uh so they
have to play very aggressive openings
the money out of your house yeah out of
the house yeah you know I played in a
North American open I think with
kaidanov and he drew round one Drew
round two Drew round three we drew round
four I said I said excuse me this is a
Swiss this isn't a around that's right
yeah yeah right so yeah this is what
happens sometimes if you have too many
draws in a Swiss that's right so many
players uh had to be very inventive
people like uh kin Demitri gurovich Nick
deeran all of them played the benoni
stuff with black and more I'm sure there
were more and all kinds of odd openings
people like fedorovich and Joe Benjamin
also had to play all kinds of OB obscure
openings especially against lower rated
players yeah and when I say low players
I mean just under the Grand Master yeah
24 25 exactly that's not so easy to uh
to be you can't really afford to draw
with black a lot that's right so they
have to take a lot of Gam
and uh yeah of course when you play it
against at 2600 f a g solid grandmas
that can be very hard and he played
Knight
C5 another Pawn Sacrifice from uh Arthur
Shen right this one I think he was I
think this one he was forced upon but
Les we forget when he just sits and
plays anything can happen when he
sacrifices a pawn or loses a pawn he
gets really excited
well you knew my prediction before the
game
so you claimed he will win yeah do you
still think he will win I always think
he'll win he wins every game why would I
think he wins yeah certainly in the last
four rounds yeah all right so let's go
ahead with the the third game of the
day yay now that's a
game what happened there this reminds me
of a Family Guy when they show Quagmire
these pictures and he says that's a
woman that's a tree that's a house
they're showing him pictures that's a
chess position that's a now we're
talking yeah oh yeah okay so he played
G5 immediately I didn't I thought I'd we
haven't seen this position at least I
don't remember seeing it the PA is
already on B5 can we go back up yeah
you're right he played Queen F3 as we
expect B5 as expected they're always
playing A3 in this tournament yep and
now a A6 the only idea could play C5
that's right and then maybe C4 yeah so
G5 came quickly Knight H5 is expected
Bishop back to E
I'm assuming that he wants to move the
queen at some moment yeah and
immediately harass that Knight also
after C5 whether the Knight goes to E2
or B3 C4 is winning the bishop it's
trapped on D3 so he's like okay now my
pieces won't get attacked man Bishop E2
leaves a strange feeling though like
that's not what she wanted to do that's
right but also there are other things so
here both sides are relinquishing
something here he's giving them the
beautiful D5 Square what a square to
give and the queen will have to move
again however Knight D4 is going to have
to move and right behind it there's a
Pawn on B2 uh that the bishop on G7 is
already drooling over so the big
question is I'm assuming Queen d8 the
natural response I cannot believe he's
going to go elsewhere do you see him
going another to another square that
looks like a good Square I mean it's
going to be really crazy to move
elsewhere I think no I agree I like
Queen d8 so Queen d8 seems like the most
normal and then the Knight has to move
somewhere I'm assuming B3 there's no
other safe Square yeah and then Bishop
takes B2 what is going to happen
here I was pretty sure why was he going
to Castle a queen side now I'm not sure
until now until now yeah exactly no I
won't be surprised if he castles King
side this seems like White's positions
in shambles yeah I I don't know I think
this is a bit much right yeah cuz minute
play F5 the Knight E5 is coming yeah
yeah what is this junior
chess
so this is very
exciting very interesting that he rushed
with Knight D5 that means he has to sa
the
pawn what is he seeing that we are not
see right because if he just played
Knight B3 then his he would be safe on
the queen side oh yeah is it possible
that he's planning Knight
F5 because the Knight on H5 is
hanging could that be the
idea
I know I feel like black has a lot of
good moves they may not get checkmated
but I like them let's start with the
first one well I'm not I'm afraid to
make a move me too I could take the
Knight or take on B2 now definitely he's
gonna play Knight F5 oh yeah it has to
be no no way he going to go Knight B3
you got to go Knight F5 yeah yeah that's
even more of a chess position mhm now
the cool and calm Knight
C6 stopping Knight E7 no chance Knight
takes G7 yeah see how cool and calm that
was yeah until well then I take back
yeah it looks yeah you're playing it no
yeah I want to save my Bishop yeah
Bishop takes B2 white has to sacrifice
more alternatively you could have also
taken the Knight on F5 first I don't
know if it makes a
difference
huh and now can I just move my Rook Coy
a shot Chandra style Rook B1 yeah Bishop
takes if Bishop takes A3 Maybe I'll just
Castle the bishop is really offside mhm
and I'm ready to play all kinds of
Bishop h97 is embarrassing yeah that's
very very
costly well let we forget that instead
of Bishop B2 he could have taken on F5
or now he can take on
F well with a bishop
also I was afraid to take with this is
messy this after taking he could play F6
yeah you're comparing this to your
favorite soccer player Messi yeah this
is even more messy than
Messi yeah if he doesn't go to jail for
tax evasion he's doing good
yeah yeah this is uh this is what's
going to happen too I think oh yeah
Queen d8 and he hasn't played Queen d8
yet no and let's of course this is a
really good position to ask it has to be
all zeros right I don't I'm pretty
certain it always says all zeros matter
what's the position is what I'm pretty
certain of
yeah all zeros it always says
that no likes white yeah likes white
after either
Queen A7 or queen d8 because of that
knife F5 knife F5 how could I miss knife
F5 my own move wow pretty
incredible when you say it likes white
less than one though right yeah okay but
white is they're going to be down
material white does have some Initiative
for
sure oh so this game is developing
players look look really
unhappy yeah I think it's because
they're tired yeah both players are like
ah this is too you saw young 's recent
yawn yeah yeah feeding time at the zoo
maybe he's having a good day though yeah
better than yesterday so this game
doesn't matter for the top three or four
places but it matters but it's exciting
chest nonetheless it's a bonus yep okay
okay so are we waiting to see how black
is going to choose his strategy we will
jump to the next game it's just a jump
to the left
and still looks good for
white yeah yeah white play the expected
H4 fix the
pawns yeah he had a dream of putting a
knight on C4 opening up his Bishop on B7
even probably at the cost of a pawn
white says not enough today3 Queen B5
and look I'm not I'm not saying I don't
like Queen B5 but you don't like I
really don't like Queen B5 it's just a
waste of a Tempo or two yeah I'm going
to play Rook Rook C1 and now I'm going
to play my favorite move
soon Bishop F1 oh Bishop F1 my favorite
move
yeah why is the queen on
B5 I don't know no that's not good if he
tries to play like Knight C6 and queen
B4 is Queen might get in trouble
there that's also The Rook is coming to
C7 that's even more yeah that's also
good yeah Queen B5 is not
good ah and he went back to D7 after
Rook C1 oh really yeah so you think Rook
cf1 draw
agreed here is here is a prediction no
no that's a clear prediction give Mike
hmer something to do exactly yeah Queen
B5 not not a good move definitely not my
goodness so now maybe we're expecting
move like Bishop
H3 yeah that's tough you really have to
be on your toes like if the bishop was
already on H3 then Bishop takes E6 Pawn
takes E6 Rook C7 is already the a you're
sneaky really yeah does this this attack
can come FAS
m a very loose position for black I'm
not saying he's lost but he I think
every move he has to calculate the
tactics that's yeah Bishop on B7 is just
terrible Bishop B7 9 A5 also leaves a
lot to be desired I think kran Han
intentionally lost to Tempo to give Yan
Leo a winning position oh he's playing
ruang Lee well in that case in that case
what I said made no sense you always
want to give Yan Leo a winning position
so he can mess it upus but yeah now
ruing Lee by the way no stranger to not
winning winning positions so more than
once
yeah no he has to be very happy this
looks just just very pleasant very
beautiful both Knights are better for
white The Bishop's better more more
space better structure everything
control the dark squares but we've been
saying this in a lot of games and then
at the end somehow that side didn't win
so we you know that the toughest task
sometimes is just winning those one
games because if he plays Bishop H3 of
course I don't think that this game that
you were looking at there's big numbers
now for white okay we'll see in a second
those numbers seem big but can we first
see what happened in the roof angang me
because he made a move he did and I'm
curious what he played he did not play
Bishop H3 what did he
do looks like he played Bishop F3 just
based off scre that's right that's
that's one of our that's one of our
favorite moves if I can ever find the
position Bishop F3 there we go Bishop F3
yeah and there isn't even a knight there
exactly that is unusual very
unusual but this looks like White's
begging to sacrifice somewhere but he
doesn't know where yet but somewhere
yeah I'm starting to wonder if Rook C1
was really necessary though because I'm
thinking maybe he's going to go King G2
Rook H1 G 4 MH and just right mobilize
things and H5 is going to become a heavy
move and
uh I don't know black is really black
has nothing to do he's like thing is if
black tries to trade all the Rooks on
the sea which you would normally do now
you're really weakening H5 now when I
sacrific there then I think I just come
meet you that's very reminds me of the
very famous game uh which I'm sure you
know well win on carpov right from what
87 something like that yeah where we
supposed just give him the business and
then
he somehow he made some mistakes and car
off one anyway but wi just crushing was
very exciting very similar position to
this yeah of course I lived in Belgium
for four years and that was after that
game but became good friends with Luke
we know many Lukes V wayy Armon vatti
I'll call him Luke winon and he'll they
all spell it differently all right but
if I call him Luke winon he'll say who's
that probably sorry he name from the
past yeah and what game did you say has
big numbers sir uh the one we were just
looking at where did it go
this is where it went yeah I thought it
was saying that White's up over one
now in this position after Knight F5 Al
because he is saying it although these
were the moves we expected
right so again kudos to Yu that
appreciates correctly that Bishop takes
B2 even though BL can win two pawns the
initiative is more than going to comp M
Brad is waiting for white to be plus two
then he can start fighting back yeah but
so far without success so hopefully mik
hasn't won a game this tournament yet
lots of draws but no
wins yeah that is correct we have two
players who haven't won and two players
who haven't lost it's usually when they
play each other then the things turn
around
yeah so this is really the exciting game
of the day wait you're not what about
this
game that's not the exciting game it's
funny but why play F3 King F2 oh you
know you know how there's like the
Evergreen and the immortal game I have a
name for this one yeah the laabi the L
we're going to call this one the laabi
yeah but Luke played F3 L smiling he
must have heard us yeah F3 King F2 he's
trying to you know Muffy it up yeah and
queen C7 tickling the pawn on H2 and I'm
guessing that one of the G or H pawns is
going to advance again no but this isn't
so boring anymore no no cuz E3 is
weak no now I'll take
black you put my Pawn back on F2
yeah which is which is good for Luke cuz
he's trying to get a worse
position the
LA it's
La yeah draw will be agreed here at some
point what move is it you think so move
20 yeah I'm giving it up to 15 moves
yeah up to then I'll move 36 then
somebody can win no no before somebody's
going to make a draw yeah but if they
get that far then
then I don't think so three sets of
minders are out nothing's happening one
weakness on three I can easily defend it
a million
times no not many
breaks that was the breaks yeah okay
back to our and battle of people in
first
place Knight C5 C4 as predicted by the
engine right and by us yeah and saying
that uh well White's an extra PA but
black has compensation with his
potential two Bishops
[Music]
mhm yeah whenever I think Arthur lost a
point won he always says he sacrificed
it and since he wins every game I
believe him no no I think that this time
well maybe he will say he sacrificed it
yeah we'll see how he does he was
thinking way too much to
uh to Define it as a
sacrifice so now of course before he
goes Bishop A2 with the idea of B4 and
that's really going to be ridiculous so
we assume that he's going to take that
annoying Bishop followed by C6 trying to
revive his own Bishop on B7
and uh yeah the computer prefers white I
think it's an objectively Fair
assessment but I think that in the
junior chest we've noticed that just
because you're up material if you're
facing some asymmetrical things you you
become a little they become a little
discombobulated so the bishop on on the
long diagonal might have some things to
say later that Bishop on B7 yeah now you
wanted to see a marshall here you go
yeah I got I got a yeah exactly some
version of a exactly exactly it's the
kind that Marshall never envisioned
yeah and we have all the stuff we
predicted on board two I see so Jeffrey
Shong did take and play B4 yeah so in
other words leang decided to uh that
it's now on ever he has to play B5
anyways I have only one
question where is the light Square
Bishop can you go back a few yeah you're
right I thought there was an extra pair
pieces on the board what happened to
they traded on B5 this way Knight takes
B5 oh he took with the Knight yeah I
didn't notice I was like wait wasn't
there a white Bishop Knight B5 and he
took with the bishop and okay that's
very reasonable disallowing B4 MH so now
he had to pay with his Bishop okay now
c4 doesn't gain a Tempo so we can try to
play Knight E2 Knight D4 quickly
okay now the question is what to do
next I'm not so sure that that trade was
in Black's favor you know because that
light Square Bishop for white wasn't
really doing so much behind his own
chain of Pawns and potentially the black
Pawn on C4 now well first I want to take
on C5 and then take on
B5 yeah I'm wondering if black can
somehow get his Knight to D3 after C4
it's just really hard to do I'm also
threatening B takes C and the bishop on
f4 on the long no I think he's going to
play C4 in fact he was about to play C4
and then he heard me uhhuh you could
tell by his body movement
it's funny all the clocks are always on
the same side because the Arbiters can
see them they face the audience that's
right so they always have black pieces
sit there but a Wonder's
left-handed yeah that's a dis he have to
yeah I wonder if a Wonder could choose
to send on the other side but decided
not to or if they're not giving him the
choice maybe for ggts that would be
complicated that's right so we are
expecting if C4 then F3 so that Knight
G3 can move and then Knight E2 Knight
D4 and he played C4 white
right it's a
bon yeah it's normal yeah you always
like
white then white resigns always like
white you always like white until he res
yeah you remember the last round and you
do you're the only person sitting in
this chair Who would know what I'm
talking about B of seano yes in Vegas
2001 it was a bononi we liked white and
then we didn't and then we didn't
because we like seano cuz he won in the
last round too being brave with black
you're still surprised yeah I was amazed
yeah it looked like the most comfortable
pairings for bar but there's a guy who's
like playing the Bon plays for a win he
doesn't say oh no I'm paired up he plays
his opening yeah well it's like he he
he's not afraid of anybody so and he got
his grandm title recently right like yep
a year ago or yeah if you had beat me in
the last round of a norm tournament he
would have got his title but and I won
in the next tournament he got his title
is that why you're known as The Dream
Crusher that's why I'm known as that
that's one of the Reas the norm
preventer that's one of the reasons I'm
known as The Dream Crusher yeah
one so many other reasons like when the
ice cream truck comes I'm the dreamsicle
Crusher uhhuh impressive yeah maafi is
pretty impressed yeah very impressed
yeah so C4 then again she's very easily
impressed yeah Wonder looks pretty happy
okay so here's what we expect F3 never
to play F3 especially in this position
F3 he might play Rook F E1 I expect that
and then how are you going to play
Knight D2 Knight D4 well then I won I'll
play
E5 that's an not right but Rook E1
that's what I expect yeah yeah Jeffrey
would never play
F3 well he didn't play either he played
Rook A1 Rook A1 well he saw an open file
and he decided to get it he put his
Bishop on the same diagonal as The Rook
okay he wants to play Rook A5 and take
the pawn or Rook
A7 yeah so if Bishop D Bishop D7
defending the pawn then D6 is hanging so
I'm just going to play Rook A5 and take
the pawn on B5 no defense well does a
queen C7 move that makes some sense but
if he puts the queen on
C7 then maybe Rook F E1 and
always aim to push at some moment yeah I
like Rook A1 didn't think of it yeah but
never play F3 so that was good I approve
yeah I think at some point the opponent
is going to be on A3 so he can REM
maneuver his Knight to D4 I like the
Knight on G3 he's stopping well he's
stopping but he's preventing Knight H5
from being strong that's right yeah but
once Knight moves the Knight H5 the
bishop can just we draw back I like the
Black Knight on F6 not going to H5 not
going to D7 just blocking the
bishop yeah very
limited yeah this is a real Jeffrey kind
of game just trying to control the game
yeah it's starting me to remind a little
bit the like the game from yesterday
where he was M pressing the right
buttons controlling everything
eventually cashing in unfortunately for
him not cashing in not cashing out
yeah
all right down the list
please wait a minute here let's go back
because he didn't take the bishop you
not take the bishop no he played C6
right away uhuh takes takes he got his
Bishop active but he didn't take the
bishop on B3 he likes his active Knight
on C5 and so now the question is yeah we
can't really go to actually I was say we
can't go to A2 but we
can we we can because we are threatening
yeah maybe yeah I was thinking Bishop C2
C takes B5 Knight F7 and I have another
question for you too many lines to
calculate why can I not play c t B5 now
right that's one line I'm looking at
then I'm not sure I understand what Al
did though right then if I play Bishop
D5 or Knight B3 I'm sacrificing another
Pawn I don't know how many pawns I can
sacrifice there's a
limit okay but the computer is not
entirely crazy about
that oh I see why if he takes the Knight
B3 Queen B3 Knight Bishop D5 five right
oh and I can't really defend my Pawn in
a useful way mhm yeah and black has
really active pieces okay right so
that's the idea so instead the bishop
just has to withdraw C2 for example I
guess defending the D3 what is the
computer preferring A2 right the prefer
you know the computer is preferring A2
for some reason that's too complicated
then D3 is hanging well exactly because
F7 what is this junior chess yeah yeah
they're supposed to play slow boring
position or R Lopez not every move is a
sacrifice well now we see why Arthur has
all decisive games every move sacrifice
is a pawn so that's right draw yeah I
wish he would have taken that Bishop he
would have been more more correct and
more exciting never trade yeah you see
your rules are making it's very tough
tough for us too yeah CU I like the two
Bishops yeah so my rules
are they're fighting each other
sometimes they contrad get rid of the
two Bishops but don't trade so it's not
easy well Arthur Arthur doesn't look
unhappy so either he's pretending really
good or he likes sacrificing all his
pawns oh here comes oot moving quickly
in the super tactical position Bishop A2
is what I'm expecting no anything but
Bishop A2 yeah you positive I have every
other move okay
yeah let's take a look and Bishop C2 any
move Bishop a to all
right so white a plan ahead am i
counting right you are yeah
and black just has like active
pieces yeah sort of like a
marshall
close it's as close to Marshall as we
were going to get from the starting
position that's
right and the computer prefers white a
little bit Yeah by a little bit 86 he's
suggesting 86 Knight F3 take on C4 and
queen C7 and bring the Rook to the
center well listen it's a pawn yeah but
the actual realization of that pawn is
going to take a long while the computer
line followed by Rook ad d8 and black
has good activity for a pawn yeah the
Knight on C5 is good the pawn on E5 is
nice not as good as taking the bishop
initially but
um yeah black doesn't have two Bishops
yet still playable still playable very
interesting game
okay now he's Arthur once again alone at
the board thinking wow n G8
uhhuh and Knight
C6 well he played Queen B5 to D7 play
Knight A5 to C6 well he managed to
create a weakness by playing B3 but I
don't think it has any mean night E7 to
G8 Rook f8 to h8 always back to where
they belong right well if the game ends
at some point but I can really quickly
set his pieces up he's getting ready May
ba Bishop C8 Queen d8 all just you know
quick falls into place fast yeah white
look at all the complications he has
he's going to have to work harder yeah
Knight G what would uh aach Chandra Say
by that a monster
resignation wow this looks terrible for
black yeah but do you understand the
move Knight H3 because I not sure I do
oh white just played Knight H3 yeah
before Oh okay does he want to go to G5
and maybe I think he wants to put his
other Knight on F yeah I think he wants
to play Knight G5 Knight G2 and then
either Knight F4 or queen
F4 yeah Knight F4 and then put a queen
on C2 or D3 and we're attacking H4 5 e67
ng6 one of the sacrifices has to work
eventually yeah black is really deprived
of any no yeah ex I guess the main point
is what is black going to do black is
stopping Queen F6 check permanently
black is in defensive mode yeah and it's
going to be really hard it's going to be
really tough I
think if carpov was wide he would double
on the C file and not even play on the
king side and black would be like wait
were you beating me yeah okay with the
the players still thinking and US
debating on what should be played
waiting for moves this is a great time
to take our first long break of the day
uh we are going to leave you with a
puzzle by one of the players something
to do while we are away but we promise
to be back within 15 minutes with much
more action from the eighth round of the
2015 US Junior close Chess Championship
from the chess Center chess club and
Scholastic Center of St Louis Ben fold
and a Freedman looking to see you right
back
I'm Mike maeni manager of the Cardinals
and chess fanatic many people don't know
that St Louis has a chess history as
rich as its baseball at the world
renowned chess club and Scholastic
Center of St Louis across from the World
Chess Hall of Fame our goal is to teach
play and promote the sport come to the
Central West End and experience all that
chess has to
offer
[Music]
e
for
[Music]
you could fly to
Venice or
Paris or even
Copenhagen you could fly all over the
world but
why when you could just come to St
Louis your trip begins at explor St
louis.com
and just like that we are back with our
eight round coverage of the 2015 US
Junior Clos Chess Championship from the
beautiful chess club and Scholastic
Center of St Louis before we left for
the commercial we have left you with a
puzzle by one of the players in the
event and uh let's see the solution to
it it was by Yan Leu playing against
manavan and we can see a serious
amassment of pieces white pieces around
the black king we can see that black is
suffering from a little bit lack of
space and in position like this
especially with all the black pieces
kind of visiting on the left side it is
no surprise that there is a very
decisive shot in this position Yan
played his move Knight to F6 check
forking the king and queen leaving black
with no choice but to take but after G
takes F6 Bishop takes F6 and of course
the dark squares told the story now
Queen G5 Queen H6 are coming mate is
inevitable and black had to throw in the
towel shortly thereafter I positive that
most of you have seen Knight F6 Jack and
full credit for solving it now back in
the studio we have a very special guest
and none other than the founder and
president president of the St Louis
chess club and schic Center Mr Rex
singfield himself welcome to the studio
Rex thank you Grandmaster I'm happy to
be here and I want for the record I want
to say I did whisper to Ben did I not
true during while you giving the
solution while you were giving I
whispered the solution giving
confirmation again to the famous Axiom
that even every once in a while a blind
squ finds an
acor yeah so kudos to you and Jennifer
thank you so much you're a long time
creature yeah absolutely yeah she she's
responsible I'm in charge of the
mistakes she's in charge of the good
moves we split responsibilities that way
oh interesting and very every once in a
while in a certain chest server that
will remain nameless I uh have to say
something to Jennifer and I see that
she's busy and I check what she does and
then I see that she's giving USS lesson
so this is still that's you know that's
when she deserves hazardous duty pay and
overtime double pay and things like that
for putting up with me there you go full
credit to Jennifer as well so um you
must be very excited for the uh third uh
tournament with your namesake is coming
next month well I am excited about that
I'm also excited about this tournament
and I'm doubly excited about the
tremendous job that you and Grandmaster
fold are doing I was watching you from
our place in Central Missouri and people
are gathering around and saying what is
this I said what is this I said this is
the strongest Junior tournament taking
place in this solar system at this very
moment absolutely L only in this one yes
and uh actually they got they got quite
excited they said you can do that live I
explained the whole process of this is
like TV around the world they couldn't
believe it they were quite fascinated by
it you guys are doing a wonderful job as
always and the players are doing a
wonderful job we got some excitement
here two top guys five out of seven and
we got these young guys a wander
everybody's making us wander what he's
going to do huh exactly two-time world
champion for his age group oh amazing
and fantastic chess the strongest Junior
ever by far yes amazing ratings people
we have a player over 2600 that hasn't
happened before and uh Bobby Fisher and
move over huh EXA exactly Bobby Fisher
move over a Grandmaster at a very young
age gmel Jeffrey Shang very very
exciting and um yeah like we do with all
our guests including a 5-year-old who
sat there at the chair all the way to
strong players we are going to challenge
you with giving an opinion about the
game oh my and we're going to
have the game that's very important the
game you got to give me an easy one
where there's just Kings on the board
because that one I can solve that'll be
that will be in three or four hours
until then let's take a look at this
game so here we have a game that gives
us our money's worth oh these are the
top two players absolutely and uh yes
and I am elect Arthur Shen uh just uh
pitched upon PA we don't know yet if he
sacrificed it or lost it yesterday he
did it and he claimed that he saw it and
he intended to do it this time we are
not sure but he definitely has some
compensation for it Ben can you explain
little this is very shocking Rex might
not know Arthur had one out of three and
then decided to win four games in a row
I win four games in a row now he's tied
he's tied for first and aad shandre had
three half out of four and was cruising
but you know isn't that characteristic
of most of the big tournaments we have
here we get the unexpected that's right
we' come to expect the unexpected you
just can't predict what it's going to be
that's right I mean last year who would
have thought of Fabiano doing what he
did exactly and here fate headed that
all the way to round eight the most
important game of the tournament is
going to be played saved almost for a
photo finish yep and we can see that in
this position though black is uh down a
pawn he has ample compensation
especially we can see the bishop on C2
is a very bad piece almost as bad as the
agreement with Iran that happened today
right almost at the same level no
nothing can be that bad nothing that bad
but White's got a strong Bishop on
C6 black black exactly that is the
compensation exactly as a matter of fact
the Black Knight on C5 had a chance to
get rid of that Bishop on C2 when he was
once on B3 and the computer preferred
that choice um Shen decided not to do
that trying to prove that that Bishop is
almost like a bad Pawn on C2 white is
really hoping to explode the position
see the the pawn advance to D4 at some
moment and uh open some light to that
Bishop but I think black's test is going
to be not to allow it now we're
expecting a move like Queen C7 holding
on to the pawn on E5 definitely don't
want to lose that and followed by Rook 8
to d8 sitting on that D3 pawn and
accentuating the weakness on D4 would it
be fair to say that in general Black's
compensation is much more activity than
white absolutely more space the weakness
on D3 and the Beautiful outpost on D4
not so much that he can put a piece into
it but white can just not use it that's
right so again we are very excited to
see how the game will continue we are
expecting Queen C7 and uh yeah we will
see in a second and uh while we have you
in the studio tell us a little bit about
the tournament uh now the tournament has
become a part of uh not just an
independent tournament on itself but
also a part of the grand chest Grand
chest tour yes it will be the second one
this year of course the one in Norway
being first and uh we're excited about
this Prospect there'll be three
tournaments this year and I fairly sure
there'll be four next year we might grow
to five
to five or six and then we have to make
a decision because you can't expect the
players at that rate to play in every
tournament we have to allow them a full
tournament bu uh but we'll get there
gradually but I think it's a wonderful
thing for chess and I think everybody
owes a great debt to Grandmaster Gary
Casper off for really spearheading the
idea and frankly doing a lot of the work
most of the work uh to organize this
event and uh but isn't it wonderful when
he says you know I know of local
organizers in this country and that
country and he starts rattling them off
and we got countries all over the planet
that are able to support tournaments of
this level in this quality locally
supported I mean this is a wonderful
thing for chess yeah it's like you know
we're just entering our Heyday and in
cities that which is them you can
pronounce actually that's right and
cities that are known to other people
and you can actually get to them exactly
and in climate that you can actually
attend without having to have uh that's
right a special 10th yeah this will be
the first time a non has played chess
here at the chess club and I think more
amazing it's the first time the US has
had three players in the top 10 in the
world and they're all playing in the
same tournament which is incredible so
that'll be amazing forour and I have to
tell you a trivial piece of It's a small
world syndrome anan's mother of course
lives in India and her nextdoor neighbor
is also her best friend and that woman's
son lives next to my daughter in
Columbia
Missouri World 5050 is that not what are
the odds exactly and both of that that
man's he's a professor of accounting at
the University of Missouri in columb
both of his sons are members of the
chess club small world indeed incredible
stuff yeah so uh yeah we are just in a
and uh you were mentioning Ben was
mentioning the top three players uh in
the United States being top 10 in the
world and uh anybody that thought wow
that's some exclusive Club no not
exactly the US Championship coming back
coming next year somebody a wild card or
somebody who qualifies might actually
have a chance to play all three of them
in one event the winner of this
tournament going to incling exactly and
this is that was my next sentence
exactly won't that make it the strongest
us the last us Championship was the
strongest ever but I think next
one the strong when you 2800 player I'm
positive that without when Wesley SS
number three that's that's right that's
a tough tournament yeah exactly exactly
so sort of like the Cardinals playing
the Tigers isn't it Ben well maybe maybe
not this year but in previous years in
previous uh so Ben any questions to our
guests yeah so uh you said next year you
think there might be four or five
tournaments for the for the The Grand
Tour do you think this tournament's
going to going to expand and have it
seems like every year we had four
players the first year we had uh I guess
six players last year that's right and
then we have 10 players this year do you
think it's going to get bigger I think
it's going to stay at 10 all the
conversations I've had uh we think 10 is
the most manageable number of course
it's a nine player a nine round robin
tournament it's pretty hard to get much
bigger than that now I hope you're
friends with the fire marshall because I
think when they have the autograph
session and we have an oncoming as we do
the other top players last year it's
going to be pretty crowded here at the
yeah it is it is I know it is it's a
wonderful thing going on here in the
Central West End it's beautiful yes I've
attended last year for the first time
and I must say it's someone who has
visited the world championship matches
uh Tata in Holland linaris in Spain uh
that was definitely the most intimate
and the most uh impressive showing I
mean this was really uh thank you more
players of of the the highest caliber at
the same time very uh also very
accessible to the when we saw Carana
just playing Blitz chess
with hanging I know this is what I
understand I wasn't here the first day
they said you should have been here I
said why is that he said well Lana
ronian W wandered in sat down to the
table looked at somebody said let's play
chess that's right play some bug house
and car play Blitz exactly it's yeah I
told Fabiano thanks for playing some
Blitz with my son he really appreciated
that he said oh that was your son I was
with everybody that's right no I mean
it's remarkable they're so skilled and
and so friendly and affable too
absolutely it's a wonderful thing it
goes with the neighborhood yep and I've
spoken to some of them and they're
extremely appreciative for this uh new
Endeavor the the chess tour because uh
the winner of the tournaments say not
only up to the price F the normal prize
for the generous priz fund the
tournaments but there's also a bonus
prize for somebody who is winning the
whole wins the whole tour beautiful much
Allah Grand Prix uh exactly and I want
to say to the 1 billion chess fans
watching in the world you're all invited
to the Central West End come and say
we'll get a hotel for every one of you
there you go with a personal invitation
from the president and founder of the uh
chess club Classic Center of St Louis
everybody's invited and uh I can tell
you again firsthand a beautiful
experience even for someone who has been
to places it's something else no no two
days are alike every day was just
different adventures and there are lots
of side events planned as well for the
championship there's going to be a bug
house tournament Blitz tournaments uh
your truy is going to host another
version of The Who Wants to be a chess
millionaire you're invited personally
please come it's beautiful and uh yeah
and we're not going to take any more uh
of your
very happy to you in the audence grand
Masters pleasure inde we'll see you
again okay great and now onto the chess
more chess let's see what happened in
the great Bon game our second game the
great Bon game wow Yes sounds like I
should be involved somehow that's right
yeah we are the heavy favorites L we
forget as as always as always yeah and
in that benoni game we really liked what
a did then we really appreciated the B4
move by uh Jeffrey MH and now let's take
a look here's the analysis he played H5
which we see a lot with the Knight on G3
that's right he's trying to undermine it
but immediately Bishop G5 freezing the
another diagonal yeah that's right this
is usually the reason we don't play H5
in a lot of openings is we're really
worried that Bishop there forever going
to stop everything does take the
pressure off of the D6 pawn and is it
fair to say w Knight E7 was already
played Rook E7 is Rook E7 sorry and now
Knight E2 Knight D4 how is that yep
that's the the usual plan right I'm
dying I'm itching to play that move
especially when there's no more e
H6 Knight E2 what's GNA happen after
Knight E2 and Knight D4 Ben I think that
black is well H5 I don't want to say
he's on the critical list but I think s
is a little iffy in the Bon we don't see
Rook e s useful and well white again can
play some serious moves here so I think
Knight E2 and the Knight is coming to D4
and oh boy yeah you wonder is going to
have some splaining to do I can tell you
one thing his Bishop is going to end up
on D7 very short L he needs to kind of
control C6 he needs to control the B5
Pawn defend the B5 Pawn but what
happened if I go Knight E2 D4 Rook
A5 he's going to get into serious
defensive mode don't you agree yeah
there's a I almost want to play F4 E5
here Rook E1 and E5 and Knight E4 I have
a lot of stuff I want to do but yeah
obviously just a simple Knight E2 Knight
D4 Knight C6 that's right Rook A5 it's
just really bad for black this is really
nice Rook B1 B4 then Rook back to A1 to
go to green right
mhm and white can do anything he wants
he can go F3 he can go Rook E1 he can
take his time he's in no rush I don't
think the timing is really a big factor
here do you agree it's not like he's
going to miss the boat if he does he can
do it slow and I don't see how black is
like if I give black four free moves but
of course he's not not allowed to just
capture and return what can he do how is
he going to improve his position yeah
after H5 Bishop G5 is a really big
concession to White a huge concession a
huge
concession now he also has idea like
maybe F4 and then Rook E1 another Rook
to E1 and then just play King H2 F4 E5
he can do anything he want he's like the
he's just all over King side Queen side
Center he's better everywhere that is a
big plus forage to twice the time yeah
I'm really any result by Jeffrey winning
this game will be a real shock for
me let's see our double checkmating game
everybody everybody's getting yeah why
not please go back a few moves
okay so we saw Queen d8 Knight F and
then we left yeah GF some thought he
with G what do you think about that you
know off hand I thought that that would
not be possible well the other hand I
wasn't sure what black should do that's
true it was hard to find an alternative
it really was difficult you were
thinking maybe bishop F5 instead but I
didn't like that either then that pawn
is coming to F6 but now look at how
soften Bishop G4 I guess if you trade
Bishops I take and you can't step Queen
H7 check that's right okay and now I'm
supporting F5 on top of everything
Knight C6 and F5 ased my goodness wow
Rook E8 and he cast side instead of
playing more aggressively what is the
computer saying about this position I am
it's going to say it's good for white
I'm positive but the question is by how
much Yeah Yeah by Just Four Points
that's it okay he's on up almost The
Rook but that's something already
happened Bishop D7 Knight F6 you have to
take this is the current
position I think white has an attack and
black doesn't I'm going to take a guess
yeah that even Yan Leo is not going to
mess up this position come on now you're
just talking silly that's right yeah
with all the bad luck that he had this
is going to be really hard to Mu you
know we were very lucky to have rex on
the show today uh you know I said hey
how you doing when I saw him outside and
he said yeah I was just running
intervals and I said outside yeah it's
over 90 deges outside and he was running
for about an hour outside so he's in
really good shape but uh I don't know if
running outside of it's 95 is a good
idea I think that several minutes rest
on this comfy chair in this schol studio
95 in our studio exactly better than the
intervals I want to give a shout out to
uh the chess Camp I usually teach at in
in Arbor the night relocation Camp run
by Jenny Skidmore I obviously couldn't
do it this year because I'm doing the
junior yeah and shabalov you we have
Alex shabalov and there all the kids are
watching so hi to the kids and alab they
claim that they missed me we'll see for
some reason Alex he only misses me when
I'm paired against him he's like I I
didn't get paired against this tourn
then he misses me yeah we all have our
dark hes yeah Beth I got tell a funny
story about Alex I went to the US
championship for the first time ever in
1994 in Key West so he flew down of
course all right and I was thinking yeah
you know I'd like to go downtown but how
do I get there should I take a cab
should I talk to the organizers and I
was talking to somebody about it they
said oh yeah downtown's great I said oh
how did you go and before they could
answer shabalov walking by says oh yeah
I have a car here I drove here here gave
me his keys and kept walking are you
serious and I I barely knew him I knew
who he was yeah oh you need to go here
I'm not driving anywhere and he like
didn't even just and walked away what
ony going fell I was like okay and
actually I think he bought the car and
then drove to the tournament that was
the only that was only mile you put on
the car yeah and somehow we drew that
tournament I didn't get crushed by he's
a pretty good sharer yeah that's right
yeah yeah so that was nice I got to
drive downtown but I guess he knew
something you didn't know what was that
you're going to become a customer over
the ches that's right that was a good
customer that was a good investment he
luned the car and ever since then I gave
him all the points yeah yeah you gave
him all the points been playing rated
chest since 1989 we played in Belgium he
probably doesn't even remember and I
lost that game and every game since so I
have a few draws sometimes it happens I
have a few draws but you'd think in 26
years I could get him once no no yeah
yeah it depends on style he's he has a
tough style so Queen takes F6 was played
Bishop to G5 uhhuh and uh well but the
attack was hard to stop no this black
white has an attack as Yer would say
white has a free attack we didn't
sacrifice any
pieces oh some PA right not too many no
two pawns two yeah but two's not a lot
for this position certainly not yeah the
rook's coming to G1 the Pawn's coming to
F6 RI takes D6 it looks like they shook
hands yeah the game over Mika had just
about they shook hands yeah because uh
so we went Queen G7 I thought he had to
defend his Pawn with Queen E5 Rook takes
D6 now we're sacrificing one pawn and
we're threatening F6 Bishop F6 Bishop H6
Rook takes D7 mik had just about enough
resigns wow yeah that's the biggest
crush we've seen in the tournament I
think yeah I think that yeah Mika is
probably very unhappy about this game I
think that maybe he's demoralized by the
his result maybe he's getting tired um
most of his games he played reasonably
well even the games that he ended up not
doing so well in yeah but this game was
just lopsided it's funny that reminds me
of a game played in the US championship
in in San Diego why is the result saying
a draw that's what I want San Diego well
because they put the Kings on the wrong
square but but I was just going to say
it reminds me of a US championship game
yeah and then uh the Arbiter came and he
said no no no you can't draw in less
than 30 moves and the guy said I lost am
I allowed to lose less than 30 moves was
very embarrassed a very embarrassed that
shows that TD yeah am I allowed to
resign no it says one zero you were half
kidding yeah I think and he is the final
position position on the live board with
the we're going to really tease him
though why would your opponent resign
based on your Technique we've seen
before oh my goodness I don't know if I
have to guess to say that after he
suffered so much but we have to say that
this time y just played a perfect game
for very brutal yeah yeah yeah I didn't
we didn't like Queen A5 Queen C7 and he
got punished for his loss of tempo
that's right and I'm noticing the
computer actually frowned at the move F5
yeah I'm curious as to why so wait a
minute let's take a look oh earlier in
the game yeah yeah well not so early in
the game but a few moves
earlier
yeah yeah he really didn't like that so
we're going to see and soon we're going
to have uh very soon as it turned out
we're gonna have uh Yan Liu joining us
right now in the
studio yep and we are going to uh mic
him in a second before we mic him let's
take a look at the uh conference room
and see what's going on on there I see
that jeffre is playing against aand
there with great intent I heard he I
heard Rufus broke in downstairs here and
took over the cameras for a second so we
had to get rid of him exciting yeah
that's what happened and they Wonder
looking a little tired I think that he
knows that he is worse he doubled his
Rooks but yeah that's not exactly I
don't think that's going to be enough no
that's not
good okay so back to the studio and now
we have Yan Leu again a guest in our
studio this time he's all miked up so we
can even hear him and not just see him
yeah hi Leon hion how are you good how
are you good so today was a game with no
stories no gifts neither by you by your
opponent just kind of a straightforward
game I think it was you woke up this
morning and you decided you're going to
look at the king and that's going to be
your target that's it well I yeah I
suppose I didn't really look at
preparation too much right but today was
it just you were in the mood for an
attack or uh I was surprised by this
opening actually yeah I've never seen G6
I don't know this line uh well we exists
but uh I did not think it was very good
yeah he ended up playing it like uh
almost like a filor with the queen went
to A5 and then to C7 just lost the tempo
we were really surprised by Queen C7 is
there a reason to retreat so quickly uh
no I think this was within my like on in
my opening repertoire but like castle
and then Queen F3 uhhuh but after that
it I mean I remember the computer gives
like a clear white Advantage just based
on what his pawns so far White's been
doing well this tournament playing E4 F4
G4 so yeah why not continue that three
continues so we guessed Queen F3 and we
assume B5 A3 made
sense but here it just looks like white
comes first
yeah so is C5 just too
early not really you already don't like
his position well I wasn't really sure
like there's a lot of things to
calculate like after C5 what happened in
the game mhm Queen d8 Knight F5 I
thought he would try to take on B2 mhm
and then
B1 Bishop A3 uh Bishop G7 I think I
think Bishop A3 is a little too risky
for the king so just Bishop G7 and then
I wasn't really like I could take of
course take an F5 and there are a lot of
options but I wasn't really sure it
certainly looks like you have a lot of
compensation yeah there's no clear one
just optically looking at the king side
SL Center compared to his development of
the were you shocked that g takes F5 uh
a little bit I thought that wasn't a
very good option intuitively yeah we
didn't think that was the best one not
that the others were
shining I thought he had to take the B2
pawn and see if he could survive the
pawn yeah attack as y would say dying on
a full stomach at least take something
for your uh suffering by the way the
computer did not like F5 here we didn't
have time because we were interviewing
Rex but like now it's a big advantage
and now the computer wants you to play
again it's a computer doesn't think that
much wants you to cast along first or
and okay kind of frowning a little bit
now saying that Bishop takes B2 is good
uh man I'd be afraid to play that if
something tells me that before I believe
the computer I want him to see churning
10 more minutes yeah not just like
interrupt when you see you mean the
computer churning or you want to see
churnin come in the studio for 10
minutes I'll let you think about that
either one yeah cuz if churnin comes in
he'll give us a good evaluation too
could be could be that he
can so in any event having not taken
after long castles you were pretty sure
you're going to win I thought there
wasn't really I wasn't really sure how
he was going to survive at this point I
think that that again uh when you think
of human versus human in Practical terms
hard to believe that anybody can hold I
mean even the 2800 is GNA feel really
bad about this position when I beat Joel
Benjamin on his birthday in the US
Championship he said oh yeah you're
crushing me and I said the computer says
equal he says yeah yeah if two computers
are playing he say I can't defend this
position no human can defend these
exctly and this is one of those I think
yeah also the comp no fun just total
demoralization and what happens if he
plays Queen E5 and saves his Pawn F6
never play F F6 are you going to play
for checkmat yeah what do you think but
there's a lot of good defenses many yeah
including but not
exactly yeah Queen H6 and queen G7 is
Nate
yeah and the referee stopped the fight
here yeah he resigned yeah we saw a
white towel jumping to the other side of
the board I guess that means yeah my
camera is still okay I've seen enough
yeah well that was a nice you may just
look simple all of a sudden after so
many ups and downs you know with the
with that barometer was going up and
down Lan is winning by six and all of a
sudden he's drawing and all of a sudden
all of a sudden you just played out a
straightforward exponential game huh
yeah well you waited until run to do it
eight round eight to do it but I think
everybody's happy The Spectators were
definitely uh they can't complain no no
they cannot complain about this game the
only person who can complain is mik but
he has no right to come so I was just
surprised by his opening Choice uh he
normally plays like he played D Carl
Khan earlier this tournament I think and
he plays a sicilian so when I saw D6 I
wasn't really sure yeah I'm starting to
think that this opening doesn't really
fit his style and I think his reactions
and decisions were really I mean this
opening is is tight Rish as it is when
losing a Tempo with Queen C7 he actually
in my opinion enters like known lines
where he he is inferior and he lost the
tempo I just that's a very bad idea I
just don't really think this Line's
really good for Block I agree I agree
and you proved it absolutely a very
strong performance today and who are you
playing tomorrow in the last one uh
Michael bodak Michael bod did they make
an announcement either CER or I assume
Tony that the round is two hours earlier
tomorrow they told us yes you think
everybody's going to
remember I think so yeah let's hope
everybody's yeah I'm never surprised at
these I I hope my camera remembers I'm
sure the TD is going to be with a
telephone number page in his hand yeah
that's right ready to make sure of that
so we're going to let you rest as always
and uh perhaps we'll see you
tomorrow very good performance
congratulations and we are going back to
our first game of the day our main
battle what is going on there has
anything changed wow has anything
changed Everything's changed everything
changed wow the position is almost
unrecognizable okay so when we last left
when Rex was here yeah black was playing
E4 the suggestion of Alex Mar I was
about to say outside Alex marer our
assistant manager of the club was
looking at this game intently and he
said that in positions like this he's
just eager to hit with E4 open up the
position I must say that I dismissed it
but it was played I guess well I of
course just looked at it very very
briefly and can he get away with it I
guess the answer is yes wow C takes B5
just as we expected not exactly the mve
that thought would wow what was wrong
with just capturing on e c takes B5
isn't Herz it's not exactly that's
amazing move so now we see all kinds of
captur time to cheat for a moment
because I want to see if our intuition
is right that's really shocking move he
takes B5 very very surprising okay of
course the computer lies likes white
quite a bit so yes he likes white quite
a bit before even but let's see go back
a little bit Yeah well he takes B5 is a
typical Junior move okay so we are in a
position where the computer after H6
Knight F6 Knight F3 I thought white was
a little bit better but nothing special
but almost by I mean it's equal look
look at the very small Advantage almost
nothing and then after E4 which it
doesn't like the move I didn't like
because it does something me too I mean
against it what's the rush but and I
guess we were right
yeah C takes B5 the computer completely
move and the thing is after all the
trading our attack is sort of gone and
white still has the extra pawns so he
decided to go for it yep I mean white
Black's trading all the pieces how's he
supposed to made him
now F takes G2 and it says that white is
computer is up by a half a point and a
half yeah it says White's winning
because not only does white still have
the two Bishops you can't really think
that White's going to get checkm when
black trades all the pieces off and
white has four four to one on the queen
side that's a big Queen side
majority but I'm trying to adjust still
because how do I still how do I get my D
PA to move and open up my Bishop can I
do that at some
moment am I have two pawns I'm only have
one Pawn but I keep thinking the G2
Pawn's going to disappear right so I
feel like the C6 Pawn are going to stay
with us on yeah if I can keep my C6 Pawn
I'm pretty happy that is the key P yeah
yeah I don't know why Arthur wanted to
trade so many pieces he had a nice uh
Buy initiative and he sort of crashed
through trading everything making it
easier for
white okay A bit of a strange decision
by Arthur and I guess chandro is again
showing his just maturity by uh playing
what I consider less obvious moves but
correct ones like C takes B5 yeah
because it traded so many pieces off the
board and I think that's why black
traded on E1 because if white trades on
E8 and black takes with the queen then
we have
D4 we don't want to play Knight takes C8
so black sort of had to trade Rooks
right but trading minor pieces trading
Rooks trading pawns that's not how you m
your opponent that's right and that
Bishop on C6 was a monster and now it's
gone so we're assuming that now he's
going to complete his development with
Bishop E3 if I told you five moves ago
when black played Knight C5 that in five
moves black would have would lose the
two Bishops and why would have the two
Bishops I would have which Bishop I
would have been hard pressed to figure
how that because it looked like Knight
takes B3 was coming instead this bishop
was saved and the bishop on C6 was
captured amazing and even Rex
appreciated the bishop on C6 m saying
how strong he was on the Dagon now he is
gone no wonder that uh everybody is
giving theard to White here and Arthur
looks a lot more miserable than aot I
think yeah his Bishop on C6 is gone and
white has a pass might have thought that
weakening the the king side is going to
do it but well you need pieces to attack
with I think he Mis assess the position
I think
so and let's look at our Bon which is
looking really good for white okay I was
just curious what was white last move in
that game but we can wait with that oh
he made a move I mean if it's oh in this
position if author is thinking of a move
then oh or maybe he's not thinking on a
move no I thought it was White's turn to
move yeah okay yeah I don't think aa's
moved yet okay Al looks like he's about
to make a move though yeah well he's
that'd be a good trick maybe he's ready
for as as we've seen in the game before
between Benjamin and
elvest in the New York open Benjamin
said it's it's not your turn you can't
move it it's not wait your turn one me
one when I was a kid growing up in
Michigan in the 70s and early ' 80s
there was a player named Alfred Becker
who was in his 80s okay and he always
said whose turn is it and my brother
said if I ever play him I'm goingon to
say it's my turn it's always my turn
yeah so whose turn is it it reminds me
of another player in the club who uh to
Anno his opponent used to ask uh who are
you rooting for he's asking his
opponent who are you rooting for in this
position okay so we saw this in the game
that a Wonder's playing we didn't like a
wers position and we don't like it
queen4 while his Rooks are very passive
defending B5 his Knight on F pinned
white at some Point's going to play e E5
and Knight E4 so we got to be careful I
have to tell you that there been a while
yeah since I've seen positions where
somebody is controlling dominating the
king side the queen side and the center
M but
separately three different entities
right here there's pressure against F6
on the king side a nice pin with the
possibility of playing F4 E5 Knight E4
on the other side there's a weakness on
the B5 Pawn pile up with the white
pieces black is completely Ted down to
defend it and in the meantime the center
is completely white well separate I'm
not shing with a computer yet but I'm
assuming this is a huge plus after Queen
H I have cheated and I have to tell you
that I thought it was going to be larger
than that yeah it says about one and a
one and a half points and I thought it's
going to be more because how to stop
this somewhat primitive of f4 E5 E4 not
E5 immediately CU Queen takes maybe
there just no counterplay right but if I
go Rook E1 followed by E5 or F4 followed
by E5 and then just Knight E4 and who is
defending how how to defend this Knight
not
easy not easy maybe not possible how can
you untie yourself from that pin that
move that njer reaction H5 was just
terrible terrible decision yeah it's
looking really good for Jeffrey we are
looking pretty good for o shot somehow
the higher rated players is always
looking good for them yeah they're so
lucky there is that saying right that
God favor the strong luck favor the
strong so this game is over this game on
the1
and looks like rofang Lee is just about
breaking through is that yeah let's have
a look and see what happened we like
black White's position quite a bit and
the last move we saw
was yeah we we were just about here
right play Knight G5 Bishop
E2 lots of Knight
[Music]
maneuvering and rofang was just playing
very very ni trying to trade all the
pieces to try to equalize the
position and the Queen's coming into G5
lots of maneuvering lots of maneuvering
boy and black only has one thing in his
favor but I hate to say it queen of
Bishop against queen of Knight here for
here the exception proves the rule allow
me the exception proves the rule allow
me to rub my hands in theight as I'm
about to show you once again what if
black plays Bishop E4 and wins the game
then then you'll feel bad Bishop where
if the bishop gets to E4 and somehow I
win the game you can almost do it you
can go Bishop D3 and you're almost there
four yeah but after Bishop D3 Knight F4
Bishop E4 tough every move wins E6
Knight takes H5
yeah yeah this isn't looking good for
black I'm willing to I'm willing to
hasard the guess that the computer gives
a bigger evaluation to this one over the
Jeffrey game and if you ask me which
position I would have yeah I'll take
white maybe the Jeffrey game you would
I'll take white here no of course white
is more winning here but I'll take white
Jeffrey game is just so fun no I like
this cuz black doesn't have counter play
yet yeah now this is plus two 2.6 two I
I have spoken for the computer we are
going to check and see if you are right
yeah this is really good for the
computer it's off the chart off the
chart you were off but to the wrong side
plus 3. something okay not a surprise
not a surprise well you got to let it
think a little more so it gets to the
right evaluation yeah okay he played
King to G8 not I think the computer says
Rook E1 with E6 or something or Knight
F4 what is going on here yeah well the
problem with Knight computer
differentiates I want to see why the
problem with Knight F4 is Rook C1 which
isn't a big problem but why let the guy
do that when you don't have
to uh say again I don't want to play
Knight F4 right now because Rook C1 he
might check me later in the game I
wouldn't want him check that's right I
don't want let him check me even once
absolutely yeah yeah yeah of course so
Rook E1 and E6 is coming man when E6
comes that's not good yeah and a good
luck yeah and if Queen E6 Knight F4 now
Knight F4 yeah yeah and again to borrow
the famous saying from the movie Taken
yeah good luck good luck yeah well Kern
hen wants this game to go six hours
because he has to prepare for his game
with Mike hmer later that's right
everything has to be in he's not very
unhappy and a move was played rookie one
was played yeah yeah ruang is at his
element is his element I like rookie one
yeah yeah he is very strong in those
positions really hard to believe that
he's going to let
go okay this game is over it's not easy
getting to these games and get to the
wrong game every time yeah but I have a
good excuse okay there we go the excuse
is operator error operator error rookie
won very strong very strong move play
six yeah it's over it's over everything
stands wrong for black he can't even
play Bishop C8 that he would have loved
to have done now if you were playing
Magnus Carlson here and you were white
oh my God I have a question would you
wake up and
apologize would don't wake up and
apologize
thank you for the compl just when I
started to enjoy the you like oh boy I'm
against yeah spoil it immediately
yeah but I've had this position before
yeah against yes who maafi Mafi of
course yeah of course now this looks
really good for why there's no defense
to E6 and the black king side collapses
yeah so we are going to have some
decisive games some some yeah that's
right we might have every game decis was
already wrong about every game so far
that's right let's take a look at the
Luke Harman game because that was the
one game that we have that was the
neglected rightfully you guaranteed
would be a draw I guarantee that yes
yeah and let's see if I'm see this isn't
I I told you black has
chances okay so let's go back when he
play one time he was attacking the pawn
he played Queen C7 attacking H2 that's
right H3 Knight here Knight here
everybody's happy yeah it's just good
for what it's just good for
black there we go infiltrate
H4 well it's not what I would have
played I think this is slightly over
ambitious Queen H4
check yeah we both sides are going to
yeah
but I know I know who I like now black
is really taking over here but who need
here come on I told you remember what I
said I I the prerequisite was that white
will not or black will not do something
crazy and he goes H4 yeah and I can just
play HG here and then attack the E Pawn
Knight F5 you really can't defend
yourself yeah we like we like black I
don't have to take on E3 right now I can
I can just play HG and you have really
hard time defending E3 that's right if
you play Queen D2 I'll play Knight F5
that is right that is right absolutely
right I don't know you're losing
everywhere no I mean white has nothing
on the queen side and black is just
attacking yeah you know in the immortal
words of Robert dairo in The
Untouchables yeah you got nothing you
got nothing yeah you're all talking a
bad that's right yeah I think five
decisive games today we might you
guarantee it
no I ran out of guarantees let's see way
that guy's going to win that guy's going
to win yeah we're going a five decisive
game it's very right now is the is the
most realistic outcome yeah what did I
say three draws yeah I'm the worst there
go maybe I said two draws no no I
remember it was five decisive games I
remember oh yeah I remember it all along
like it was yesterday Best Line this
week I'm the worst but the truth hurts
yeah okay okay so this looks really bad
for Luke Harman vat looks good for bodc
yeah okay let's continue our little tour
yeah let's go back to the beginning yeah
10 years later style it's 10 years later
10cc that's 10 years later okay okay so
takes Bish reasonable and now instead
taking on D3 trading more pieces he
played Knight G4 of course taking on D3
just makes sure that white protects his
C6 Pawn without C6 Pawn is going to be
good that's not appetizing so he play
Knight G4 and he's and white White's not
going to move and then he'll play Queen
H4 and then he'll be happy that's the
plan
oh thank you very much for preventing a
blunder yeah you were like why can't I
just play this I was just thinking about
D4 and I'm like too excited about Queen
H4 Queen H4 is tough so is it possible
to just say okay I just want to play H3
in this position yeah if you play H3
Queen H4 you don't have Queen H1 made
cuz there's a knight on G that's right
so that that kills
that not to mention I can take on G I'll
play uh Knight E5 maybe you'll miss my
other threat I have a chance right
that's right you want to see Knight F3
check well I mean it's not without uh no
Knight G4 I like
it why didn't the computer suggest it
back when you were looking at a
computer's no good Arthur Shen won four
in a row computer hasn't won any games
that's right yeah that's one way to say
it uh winning four in a row is tough
wait what happened here you remember the
last time you won four games in a row in
around Robin I don't remember the last
time I played four games in a around
yeah that's true four games in a row
round says white is winning I did it
once and you will not believe the move I
believe it you will not I'll believe it
D4 yeah yes it's like Queen H Queen H4
he's going to take on G2 King takes G2
but I promise you yeah that this is not
going to happen King takes G2 well I
don't promise you but I don't think it's
G to happen that I can go to F3 or F1 I
like F3 because it attacks both KN you
attack two knights yeah you can't play
Knight E5 check anymore we're going to
take a horse here yeah well okay Knight
takes E3 okay thank you for the training
yeah no you're welcome no I have another
surprise Rook H1 is attack that's that's
right but black has a lot of defenses
yeah stopping the clock yeah offering
his hand yeah signing the score sheet
that stops Rook H1 in all cases getting
up and running yeah yeah lots of
reactions so you guarantee D4 will be
played but you know if there's one
player that could play this move here in
this tournament it's oot yeah yeah
because he has this uh yeah I think Mike
cover would play D4 every time after
Queen H4 he'd be like oh Queen H4 then
he'd be forced to find King G2 you know
this is really funny that you mention it
sometimes I see my student playing a
line and I'm amazed that they saw it
only to see that the next move they had
completely no clue they just overlooked
it of course yeah you know it's like the
famous saying uh with somebody I forget
which Master of the past was
complimented for amazing Port sacrifice
and they talked to him about and said
well did you see a way to defend it he
he just couldn't he couldn't see how to
defend it so he deci to Second it yeah
so it's all a question of
perspective beautiful
life all
right so as long as white doesn't see
Queen H4 he's sitting pretty if he sees
it he's scared of it then he yeah the
worst part is that even if it happens it
doesn't happen so exactly yeah D4 looks
really massive
here and AA is looking up thanking the
gods for his Poss
rechecking a little short on time what
move is what move do we have of his it's
move 24 yeah yep so he has to speed up a
little bit but I think if he calculates
the D4 variation correctly life is going
to be very good he's just going to win
technically man I haven't seen that this
tournament I've seen checkmates but not
technically winning well I mean can you
imagine if he goes D4 the Knight moves
then H3 the Knight has to
either excuse me move back or take and
and now white is just the the rest is
just strong cuz Queen G2 really he's
about to make it he's about to make it
yeah he already had the point on his
hand over the D Pawn I think he's going
to do it and yeah aot is the kind of guy
who's going to do
it and I think that Arthur is in trouble
there was a game in tilberg uh somewhere
around 89 mhm and uh Kasparov was
playing egin and Kasparov was queening
and egin was mating him but not really
so Kasparov queened and got the ARB give
me another queen and he got checked a
couple times and ran his King out that
was it that's it couple of checks yeah
yeah but he had an extra Queen so like
the old people at my club used to say
nobody ever dies from one check y two
checks oh two checks yeah that's right
yeah Queen H4 Queen H2 is a check but if
the king runs away and you're down a
piece that's not good that's not
good yeah that's a rude answer D4 Queen
H4 King takes G2 calm you move the
Knight I go H3 you take on H2 I go to F3
and you lose
something and Arthur is already ready to
write the move chra had his hand up
again he took it down
again very very much a perfectionist
he's not going to play the move until he
re checked and rechecked and verified
and certified verified by Visa
yeah I used to have Visa but I didn't
like them so I got grandmas card much
better really yeah so I got one
yesterday as you know oh yeah yeah but
then again you signature was always
better than gold so well you know why
I'm here yeah I don't leave home without
it perfect yeah no this looks good for
Chandra but yeah if he doesn't play D4
is it so good um I think so all the
lines I mean he could play good for
white he could play H3 immediately and
after Knight takes F takes yeah but I
was going I was going to play Knight E5
and play for tricks listen we are now
just everything is academic he went D4
he did yep and then he walked away all
cool and then he walked away oh he he
just took something out of the bag it
was a microphone he dropped it and
walked
away D4 you do realize that some viewers
might be believe those nonsenses right
believe it I believe it okay
yeah no but if they've watched my videos
before they understand my chess
teachings
yeah so if Chandra wins this game I said
if yeah and Jong wins his game yeah then
Jong will be half a point behind and AR
will be a full point behind we could
still have three different people play
in the US Championship next year uh
could playing Coran Han the last one no
that's that's Jeffrey oh Jeffrey's
playing oh yeah so who under playing no
don't ask tough questions yeah and also
somebody shows up at 1:00 ready for
their last round game and I think
Jeffrey catch right yeah I see that game
is over wow F4
E5 yeah it's not good exactly what oh
the Rooks on A6 already wow White made a
lot of good moves while black wasn't
doing anything well what could he have
done yeah so after Queen H4 Bishop D7 F4
Bishop E8 King H1 very safe
no Queen C5 check ever that's right then
Rook A6
E5 and and what is in attack and what
isn't lost but Nigel Short's going to
Tweet about this game for sure because
he doesn't like the Bon so the Bon gets
crushed he's very happy uhuh yeah well I
have to tell you that the only amusing
thing about this game is looking at it
from the analysis board's point of view
and seeing the barometer right in the
middle yeah because when supp to be
something like plus a million and a half
yeah wow what a crush yeah we saw two
crushes today I mean two very lopsided
games right very amazing games and we
are going to have uh Jeffrey Shan in the
studio just in just a few minutes put
some more one Zer z uh wow wow White's
going to win four games today it looks
like it's only less than three hours
since the start of the game it's a real
yeah and two games already ended in in
crushes more some other games
are just about being
decided wow everybody's playing very
aggressively and in this game I thought
white was going to win really quickly
also and I still think that he will
somehow he stopped e what did he do how
did he he play Rook C6 yeah that'll do
it and now he played King H2 ah cuz he
was ready for Rook C1 right king6 yeah I
like King H2 and then and then Knight F4
is coming and then E6 yeah now Knight F4
I
wonder no he shouldn't play F3 so I
guess yeah Knight F4 and
something this is going to be a crush
yep H5 is hanging D5 is hanging D3 is
hanging e66 is always in the air yeah
yeah very very
lopsided again can I don't see that he
has any chance I can believe there's no
counterplay and uh just a terrible
position
yeah so we are back in our studio with
another guest we have uh the highest
rated player in the tournament grandmas
elect Jeffrey Shan another draw this not
exactly not this time a good answer not
and yeah I think that this time only the
second most win of the of the round
that's right other game was pretty
brutal that's right and I think it's
fair to say maybe Jeffrey will agree or
disagree that maybe this was his most
convincing game of the tournament we
were convinced from beginning to end
really a clean game with no chances to
the opponent I mean that the final
position to me is just deserves a
framing so I think this is the first Bon
of the tournament did you expect the Bon
might happen not at all no I don't think
does he Wonder did he ever play I don't
think Bishop d32 your normal stuff or
you played your second string uh you put
the third string guys in so he wouldn't
know what to do so I think this is a
game full of inspiration for both sides
trying to surprise the opponent he had
one chance actually I'll show
you so here we kind of liked his plan so
far we thought he did well here yes yeah
I think he has to go Knight G4 instead
of rookie a he has to do something uhuh
in order to block E5 yeah cuz he could
never play Knight D7 E5 cuz you that's
right that was a problem later on
exactly so
maybe yeah maybe this was the only time
to do that and I think I should go F3
not H3 yeah but you followed my rules so
I approved notice how easily he won
following my rules yeah he was always
saying F3 F3 F3 I said Noe Jeffrey won't
play F3 good job and now after the G
fist pump to the Grand Master fist pump
yeah and then he comes back and he says
what move should I have played F3 yeah
he's like I should have played better at
this game yeah you won too easily that
wasn't good okay so we were really
impressed with Rook B1 B4 are we easily
impressed or we should be no no this is
normal but I think that we B5 here might
be too early then right because well
then I play B4 yeah B4 anyway so but
then the position gets defined and
that's uh yeah after that it looked like
he had nothing no but actually he did
have something let's take a
look we yeah this is why I would like my
Pawn on F3 in this position uhhuh after
Bishop G5 you were doing well yeah but I
only had one concern which is if he goes
H4 here yeah so you want to play Bishop
takes Knight I'm too old for that no but
the main point is if I play Knight G2
mhm he will take on e4 Knight E4 and
F6 man this whole game surrounds F3 and
F6 moves that we never played holy
moly and you didn't have time to analyze
with him after the game
no but yeah he had to go for this and
it's not so if Knight D6 Queen D6 Bishop
F4 Rook E2 no oh I didn't see that very
or can you play Knight D6 yeah I mean
there a lot of pieces hanging on the bag
yeah this is I'm too old for this you're
young what's going on here I think white
is just winning you think White's
winning but I'm too old okay he has to
take on no no no yeah you your I think
your variation is correct so Queen D6
uhhuh Bishop F2 Bishop F4 but that that
I'm not so sure if take on D6
take on B8
yeah take on D5 I don't I no maybe I am
better here well this is not so clear is
it but I have a feeling that after
something like Rook A8
or something might
Happ yeah probably I'm better here who
who's better white is better I have a
rook he has a pass C Pawn I don't know
about I don't
knowly slightly better yeah but there
still
Theory yeah also he could just play we
looked at all H4 is play I wonder maybe
your opponent didn't see he could play
H4 because you Bishop G5 I think it's
the only move can we just go for the
crazy after H4 take Knight E4 take on e4
I think this is which one you going to
take Let's Pretend with the let not not
give up the Knight Rook on A1 that's
right okay this is a for Queen H4 Knight
D6 Bishop
H3 Bishop
H3
yeah I don't think black's even at risk
here I have a question what that's my
question I don't understand anything yet
yeah can I take on E8 I was going to
take on E8 yeah and now one oh but I can
at least take on G2 at least and oh then
it's a
perpet or maybe more I don't know
probably a Perpetual yeah this is
looking like Okay so let's not take too
far of course we didn't mean to take on
E8 yeah it's just a j I think you have
to play Knight C oh wait no okay I don't
know what to do here wait if I took on
H3 what would happen to me yeah you
should take on H3 and then Queen H3 okay
okay now let's try Knight
C4 Knight C
E4 here yeah I think Knight C4 but this
seems equal it seems equal like if I
maybe iused Queen uh Bishop takes A1 MH
and then you have to take on A1 I think
if you take on
what happen if I just take back yeah I
just take
back yeah that's going to be good for
black but if if you take on a one I
don't know it seems
equal maybe I prefer I would say unclear
but
okay yeah it's really messy but okay
Messi is better than what happened where
it wasn't messy that's right right he
just one move later and he had really
nothing I didn't understand Rook e s I
thought at least maybe he yeah that was
very strange maybe Queen D7 but I don't
know why he would just pin his pieces
like that so I think if you would have
played F3 instead of H3 then the game
would have been perfect in other words
yeah everything it would have been the
same thing without the trick yes and of
course you could never play H5 but H5
looked really
wow yeah after rookie 7 I think I have
five winning
moves so I just didn't understand yeah
now it's just a never came out of yeah
the point is after Queen E5 I play
Knight
G2 and if he plays Knight E8 I play F4
and if he goes anywhere else with the
Knight I play Bishop
F4 yeah pretty
expensive then I even win The Rook on B
because it's trapped it's trapped
yeah
W so that was a nice fun game look at
his final position what is in attack and
what isn't in take yeah what's happening
in the board one game yeah I we're just
going to talk to you about that after D4
it said white was winning like D4 a lot
yeah but I before we have no comment
before that black found the best chance
I think yeah he played Queen H4 yeah
this is what the computer wanted to play
with white yeah but it was giving white
a big plus here yeah like really big
plus huge looks like H3 wins no H3 is
too obvious I probably he did why maybe
he wants to do something
crazy so you guarantee this game will be
a draw then it'll be a three-way TI for
first no I don't care that's what you're
hoping though if you could pick the
result yeah draw is a fair result yeah
wait could you go back a few moves I
don't understand how this got so
bad we can tell you what what what the
computer said you can agree or oh he
missed 96 I think yeah so right so in
this position he should take the bishop
and play C6 and the computer says
White's a little better but now that's
right okay if uh but then a yeah yeah
yeah and here here it's still okay and
he he went too far here he should just
build like take on C4 Queen C7 Rook ad
d8 and have compensation I don't think
he in this position still okay all right
maybe has to go A5 to stop E4 go A5 no
but he could take on C4 and then play
Queen C7 Rook a
d8 and the Queen on his little that's
the best that's the computer line yeah
yeah after E4 I actually liked what
white did taking on B5 taking on
C6 and it just says White's winning no
but earlier how did white even win the
pawn oh because he played Knight G5 in
this position black played rookie at
Bishop H6 first just no no yeah the
rookie at Bishop f8 is not good yeah
this bishop f8 here immediately no I
think that's the starting of yeah then
he sort of had to go up a
pawn H6 you have to yeah yeah H6 instead
of Bishop f8 yeah
mhm but then still some weak still like
white yeah and okay this all happened
e4s too too early trading too many
pieces after Knight E6 he was thinking
and he's still thinking yeah he doesn't
like H3 for some reason maybe he likes
it too much so we're on move 25 and the
players are getting down to some time
trouble mhm all three results possible
yeah watch him play D5 now we might have
five decisive games today unlike
yesterday we had we had one that's right
that's
right so tomorrow you having uh White
against Kieran h no uh I have I just got
a double white so you're black against
okay yeah looked like kran was losing
when we lost that
was I think I'll be surprised if it's
still going on and it is it's going on
but it looks good bring it oh here we go
then yeah white has 35 minutes and black
has two black just played King H7 after
E6 well you'll be in a lot of trouble
with black winds if you you'll never
hear the end of it that will not
happen that can just not happen with all
respect with all the respect
yeah so what is going to happen here
he's deciding E7 or he takes F7 move
could could win here right he's deciding
yeah maybe he's deciding about Queen F6
too Queen
E7 of all the moves I said which one do
you like all of them Queen F6 Queen E7
E7 and E F7 I haven't you haven't said a
move I didn't like that Queen E7 with
with ef looks annoying as
heck it's the Junior tournament so it's
annoying as heck no the thing is that
you can't even sack an exchange on E6
because there's F3 at the end of all
this also you can't because Queen F7
check yeah yeah top of everything yeah
after Queen E7 it's yeah yeah every move
wins he's having a tough time yeah
that's a tough situation let's see what
the computers to be choices are man I
like Queen E7 after I queen E7 Queen C7
solid the defense wait he played Bishop
F5 in the Chandra game yeah but we're
that's a different game now you're
confusing enthusiastic about it it
doesn't matter now you're confusing
we'll get back to it
hold so wow it's getting noisy here I
don't like those moves
yeah
okay I am
here so it's off the chart winning yeah
plus a rock and the
moves move queen7 is not one of the top
three but I'm positive that it's
probably one of the I'm going to play
just because I'm curious what kind of
ranking is yeah he's he Jeffrey says
Queen C7 oh yeah it went down from sorry
my bad because Rook C7 oh there's still
a move yeah forgot about that yeah Rook
C7 don't like that position for black
okay so in this position every move wins
the computer
favors um e Tak F7 as the
best yeah and after Queen f8 F3 and the
bishop on e4 has a little issue
M yeah he win the
queen my
God yeah but he has tons of time so not
moving would be my plan letting my
opponent sit and look at this position
right yeah I agree with this technique
wait so Chandra played Bishop F5 yeah
let's look at the Chandra game where he
played not the recommended move Bishop
F5 I'm not so sure if it was recommended
or not we didn't look yet and he has
eight minutes and change to 13 minutes
so all three results possible well the
computer still enthusiastic about that
alternatively well Arthur got out of a
bad situation last round Arthur was
losing a few games that he won yeah he
was
so slightly preferred H3 but I think
that Bishop F5 is just on par I mean
just a very minus
difference also looking pretty
impressive yeah white has two Bishops
somehow instead of black having two
Bishops you see the pawn on C6 with his
friend on D5 that was hard to
meet yeah well we're going to thank
Jeffrey very much for his visit to the
studio wish you luck in the last round
tomorrow thank you we'll see if the
tournament is going to end up in a photo
finish for the race uh for the first
prize with
a yeah the guaranteed price F of $6,000
for first and they seed to the US
championship and uh yeah that is also a
good point for us a good moment for us
to take our five minute break uh please
stay with us and if you're leaving
please be be sure to return to this
channel to see the conclusion of some
very exciting games a very good chance
for five decisive games today um we'll
be right back gold night relocation Camp
there you go right back I'm Mike Mai
manager of the Cardinal in chess fanatic
at the world-renowned chess club and
Scholastic Center of St Louis across
from the World Chess Hall of Fame St
Louis status as the chess capital of the
nation is on Full display with a
welcoming environment and Scholastic
outreach program that works with over a
100 Schools our goal is to teach play
and promote the sport so whether you've
played for years or never before we
invite you to experience all chess has
to
offer
[Music]
yeah
la
[Music]
n
a
[Music]
for
okay and we're back once again with our
live coverage of round eight upon
penultimate round of the 2015 US Junior
Clos Chess Championship coming to you
live from the uh beautiful chess club
and Scholastic Center of St Louis I'm
with the legendary local Grandmaster Ben
fold and abav fredman and uh yes this is
the concluding conclusion of the round
lots of exciting show today with a lot
of decisive I think so there's already
not only two games behind us but the
rests are already on the critical list
when we're looking at uh our main game
let's go directly to it oh wait I see
that some games already finished but
this game is also I see Ru Lee must have
won yeah yeah and I'm pretty certain
that uh aren's game is going to be over
soon not with the desired result for him
yes so we left Rook E8 was played yep by
Arthur Shen MH some trades here comes
the queen trade not good for black yeah
now with a 4 to1 majority on the queen
side and uh so he played check trading
more pieces I but King H1 never trade
very nice no rush to take it yeah
because the queen is still hanging
that's right Queen H4 and then Queen
f33 yeah Black's White's King is
perfectly safe but the 4 to1 pwn
majority has to tell Knight D3 Knight F5
knif F5 Queen
back the computer is saying plus a
million yeah that's it's off the charts
because basically white has a better
position and white has two extra pawns
that's right and has white has two pass
pawns he played Rook to G1 no now
White's playing for the the attack yeah
attacking everything H6 he's threatening
Knight G7 and Bishop White's winning on
all three sides of the board now again
like in the other just a complete
rush so after this round we're going to
have Chandra and clear first Jeffrey sh
and clear second and Arthur Shan and
clear third and uh notice that lero
Frank won his game yeah let's let's go
there
please he is going to be with us very
very shortly let's take a look Bo at of
a picture of the board one more time
please
and yeah here we
go yeah we're going to go back to game
and talk about the we go about the
opening and then yeah this was the first
interesting moment we thought
yeah yeah when we get rofang in the
studio then we can talk to him about
this position exactly that's a great
idea why don't we get him okay Studio
we'll Snap My Fingers go here we go and
uh we welcome ruang Lee one more time to
the studio hi ruang and uh you had a
very interesting game uh we really like
liked it we must say let's go to the
first interesting point right in the
opening yeah if you thought Knight D4
was a bit too early because of this
Knight D1 yeah normally you wait until
the G Knight commits himself and then
after if I like if he waits until Knight
E2 I have to play like Knight C1 that's
right that's right Knight C1 Knight D1
to play C3 so here he's sparing you all
those Maneuvers the Knight had to go
back and you were pretty happy here yeah
yeah for a good
reason and you don't have to play Bishop
H6 you can play like you know D4 right
away but you thought this was a better
way of playing you already know this
position no I thought I just thought
like I should trade off his
Bishop yeah not only did we like C takes
we like Knight takes also without his D
Pawn is weak yeah but Knight takes
Knight takes Queen takes
E5 all then maybe he can play
F5 oh just a counter play against the
center or he can just stay put I mean I
thought you hard hard to realize
Advantage yeah this just looked really
nice for you yeah I thought taking was
also good on D5 yeah MH also looks
good so there was one minor tactical
hiccup the computer was telling the
people outside and they told us in this
position where your opponent played a
very strange uh move uh Queen to B5 um
actually you have a really strong
tactical move here that's not just
pushing him back you play B4 yeah
which is sort of weird the idea is
basically to trap the queen and the the
pawn on D5 is pinned and he has a lot of
issues here so if Knight c44 we take you
can't take with the pawn obviously yeah
and I think Here Comes Rook C7 yeah Rook
C1 Rook C7 a piece Queen A6 Rook C7 yeah
and Bishop F1 and B5 and Knight that's a
lot of bad stuff yeah yeah I guess it
didn't occur CU I just played yeah CU B4
is really strange because I just played
B3 the previous that's right yeah so
Queen B5 is a move because after this he
went back to D7 he want I think he want
to play like Knight C6 Queen B4 but I
can just prevent it with Knight C2 and
Bishop
yeah so pieces were maneuvered but it
seemed like you had a lot more space
than he did and a lot more ideas and the
weaknesses on the king side are
permanent yeah it's unfortunate by
trying to take over the SE file or trade
Rooks he's really weakening H5 and you
have a lot more tricks it looks like and
just a little news flash at looks like
AKA Chandra won his game against ala
Shen yep AA is going to join us in the
studio uh later a little bit later and
let's go with this game yeah did you
think you were just always winning or
just a big Advantage big Advantage I
thought you could I thought Queen C7 was
better better than Queen C8 yeah the the
E6 Pawn cuz I well I just thought it was
better placed than C7 okay that
yeah yeah and this just seemed like it
was over
yeah very strongly played the fake you
never was nice
yeah and here we you had a plethora of
good
moves EF F7 was the compet choice but of
course every move was winning y yeah now
there's no Rook C7 or queen C7 so now
Queen E7 is even better very strong very
strong Pawn looks pretty good and this
is the final position very hard to stop
so I give Rook C8 I play Knight
E6 that looks like no
fun well for you it does that's cute so
that was a very smooth Victory we saw a
few smooth victories today it looks like
we're going to have five decisive games
maybe but uh was there something
different today people were more more
aggressive yesterday we saw four draws
what's the difference I don't know just
coincidental yeah I guess this time
everybody who got a winning position
decided to cash in on it huh no no gifts
to either side no Miss yeah and all the
all the wins were just like this I mean
Jeffrey's win and Yan's win were just
blowing I can't free myself I'm thinking
that after rank winning all the games
yeah yeah rang after this game I have a
feeling that if you really cashed in
against Chandra and Chang man you could
have set really pretty
nowadays but okay still you have to be
very pleased with the way you play
overall I mean some misses here and
there but overall you're playing the
preparation in some game is really good
I mean yeah but I missed like wins in
half my games I know exactly this is the
but overall that proves you that you
could beat anybody there right I mean
it's and don't make the mistake tomorrow
remember when the next round starts we
have to get her earlier and so do you I
assume they made that announcement
upstairs you're word the round starts at
11: right yeah okay we don't want any
forfeits tomorrow so we're telling it
all I something fun to talk about but
yeah we don't want to see that and who
are you playing tomorrow uh mik okay oh
my okay well he wants the tournament to
be over loses five draws that's right
got really crushed today yeah he's not
getting any momentum by the way are you
aware of the fact that uh your
5-year-old sister was in the hot seat
yesterday yeah we she was sitting right
here we intervie her yeah and she told
us ask we asked her do you know what
your brother is raining and she says
yeah what is it 2500 but still she said
she beats you all the time not all the
time sometimes draws and and she
admitted that you were a very good
teacher and helping her and a good
brother you got comp complimented Abdu
there and I think she's playing Rex
upstairs right now that's right so
formidable opponent if if they play for
who owns this club we might have a new a
new boss a new owner yeah yeah for the
singfield cup it's going to be the uh
the Le C Le cup yeah the Le cup with the
sponsor president Rachel
Le fantastic well we're going to let you
go and rest a little bit prepare for the
last round thank you very much for
joining us in the studio good luck
tomorrow as well yeah thanks and yeah
one more game left in the the funny
thing is was the one game that we
expected to finish relatively quickly
what move are they on yeah I said 32
moves the 35 moves how much did I give
the
Max and they are already past the time
control and they're still playing well
this is white getting totally crushed
yeah
yeah White's getting checkmated and down
upon and has weak puns yeah so maybe
five decisive game
impressive but he's lucky he's going to
earn his title this game if he doesn't
lose this game now that's a Lucky Luke
yeah yeah I don't think I think that his
lucky yeah we already have four decisive
games and White's completely losing this
position yeah I thought when he played
F3 King F2 I was thinking one thing
never play
F3 yeah certainly not H4 to follow yeah
King F2 H4 you should have left well
enough alone you know yeah this looks
really bad King is exposed minus one
pawn pawn D4 is weak pass Aon good for
any ending is this plus four plus four
is my guess we can check if you want my
guess and I'm assuming that we are going
to see aad Chandra yeah aad won very
nicely play the last 15 moves just
perfectly that's the way to play him
right wellow look at the game of the
white year one one one one decisive
games haven't help you have to go down
and see the game we're want to look at
yeah the game we want is not is not
going to be one zero I don't think no no
that would that's too
lucky there we go so I would say I was
saying what Slack's up four he's only up
in change I've never been so wrong yeah
good enough every Mo decisive games
today wow yeah every move is winning
Queen E3 is good King
G7
yeah what a
round I was really impressed with ma
Brad in the first couple of rounds I
mean seemed like he was really playing
solid that's right that's right you just
can't get anything going I think that
sometimes after the first loss you just
can't get can't get back to it maybe
that's what happened to him and I also
have a theory why we have five disas of
games tonight that Rex is here that's
true that's right you don't have such a
big tourel is here
so in case there's a new boss they have
to get ready the old and the new yeah no
I heard right before they started and
they shook hands he Rex said May the
older player win
so right you know I played a playoff in
the junior for second place once me and
Patrick Wolf uhuh and as we shook hands
he said May the thinner man win that's
what he said that's what he said and did
he he did let's
see now we know you why you're not the
champion man yeah well this looks really
really really bad for white very bad
yeah just five crushes today W weren't
any flipflops really like one guy was
winning and then he messed it up they
were just that's right all the games
were 30 moves or so so we GNA have AA
Chandra with six out of
eight and he's already clinched to tie
for first he needs a draw tomorrow for a
clear first oh no I'm sorry no Jeffrey
that's right Jeffrey won nothing is
guaranteed just yet and Jeffrey has
probably the EAS e of the pairings mhm
and uh yeah we could see a two-way
three-way tie for first tomorrow or or
and we should and we should note to our
viewers that in the case of a tie we
don't have co- Champions we have we use
the tis only for the playoffs there's
going to be a playoff tournament playoff
competition and depending on the number
of the players if there's two or three
and uh if that happens we're going to
give you all the proper details
tomorrow and uh until then we are
looking already at the opening in the uh
uh most exciting game of the day the
game the most important game of the day
between AKA Chandra and Arthur Shen
Arthur was very happy when the game
ented because he continued his decisive
game streak so very good eight out of
eight yeah and as you can see we have a
regular guest in the studio the sole
leader of the tournament I am AKA
Chandra welcome to the studio AA and uh
it's about time you played a game that
wasn't suspicious very good yeah yeah
this time you didn't eat much time in
the opening and I mean I was you weren't
lost in the ending that's a good again
prep and goes out the window and I'm
thinking in the opening again so I just
played D3 even though I don't know it
too well I just played something yeah
you played D3 it's probably it was
probably a good choice cuz he said he
had prepare the mar that's right right
yeah it seemed like after Knight C3 he
just this I I knew there I knew some
stuff in this line with Bishop G4 but
yeah he played Wesley's move with Knight
B8 and then I think an that played
Knight G5 and H6 F4 that's with the idea
but I wasn't prepared for such a sharp
line like that so I just played
something normal with Knight E2 in the
spirit of the open and getting the
Knight to G3 one way or another yeah I
felt like like and he played a little
naive here I think he played well the
first few moves are maybe half normal
yeah I thought he should
go um we just had Jeffrey here in the
chair and he was thinking that uh
instead of letting you play Knight G5 he
should have played H6 at some point yeah
H6 but it's kind of awkward Mo to make
but with my Bishop on B3 it can be a
little maybe how can white improve how
can black improve his play it seemed
like his game was just bad I think he
should have gone Knight C5 Bishop E6
after in this position to try to tr
instead of bishop7 but yeah but still
white retains a slight Edge um but yeah
I mean if you once once he left the
bishop on that diagonal I mean he had to
then he has to now calculate all these
lines with right but yeah uh C3 Bishop
was just a I don't know I mean a bit of
a naive move we right now the computer
was saying that black was playing okay
here and that he should he should play
Knight takes B3 and C6 yeah that's what
his brother was saying after the game um
you know why we told his brother right
oh really of course we we W this we went
downstairs yeah so yeah I mean I thought
this is okay for me I take probably and
but yeah I guess C compensation but yeah
strangely enough I didn't really
seriously consider it neither did my
opponent I thought I thought he'd plays
C6 yeah and E4 is just a a very bad move
too much you should take on C4 go Queen
C7 yeah the computer line was this and
then Queen C7 and rook ag8 and it was
still only giving you like a small
Advantage like three or something oh
that's strange yeah psychologically I
mean Black's upon PA down so yeah we it
seemed like he more lost the pawn than
sacrificed it although we thought that
yesterday yesterday he's like sacrificed
upon yeah today today I think he missed
missed that's a big difference
psychologically when you do
intentionally or not I agree yeah and
the computer was already giving you like
huge huge numbers here like already
winning yeah yeah but you found a really
nice move d4 that was the computer's
Choice yeah I was I almost had a heart
attack for a sec because I thought Queen
H yeah I miss calculate something but
fortunately had D4 the king just runs to
F3 MH yeah this was you played like a
computer the rest of the game that's why
you won Play Perfect every that'll do it
y yeah I go a little worried here cuz
his Knights are around Mak King but I
just decid I just managed to fortunately
not blunder anything but yeah now it's
you have too many extra pawns on the
queen side now you the king side could
played Knight H6 but I didn't want to
play that I
just here and we stopped looking here
because the we didn't want to break the
television set the numbers were getting
too
high yeah it's just lost you're winning
on all parts of the board yeah a rookie
3 you didn't see that no I saw it but it
doesn't work
for a number of reasons cuz yeah King H6
Queen H3 right and here he resigned
because down a lot of material ain't
getting mated yeah right the double
whammy so that was a very clean game we
thought you played really well oh thanks
we said that about a lot of games today
they were just a lot of crushes a lot of
one zeros today yeah Z except for the
last game which will be a Z1 yeah I see
that yeah but yeah five decisive games
today is very likely so so we were
wondering did you go go out to dinner
last night or something ate something
special no how do we have all five
decisive games we had something special
last night we had a good dinner that's
right I guess maybe we inspired them by
by by his yeah so you know the round is
two hours earlier tomorrow does that
help anybody gets DET termin over with
quick more quickly so you have less ring
to do I know he doesn't help I guess the
only you yeah he always comes like he's
tired with his head messed up and I
think he needs more sleep not less sleep
but okay he's not fighting for first
place so forgive it so you going to
prepare tonight for the US Championship
next year prepare for those guys you're
all ready now still thinking about that
you forgot the Jeff half point lead so
you have to who you playing tomorrow I
wer a Wonder playing Han so uh what
you're black are you so yeah I'm black
okay so yeah so both you and Jeffrey are
black in the in the last run Jeffrey is
playing Kuran Han you're playing a
Wonder yeah and both Kuran and wonder
lost today quite miserably I should say
very very lopsided games so uh yeah
we'll see how that's going to affect uh
the game tomorrow you are leading the
tournament I guess that's a comfortable
thing but you are it's all in your hands
basically right four WIS and four draws
right yeah yeah but uh still one round
to play so have to that's right yeah of
course this is like a we're not counting
any chickens before they hurt right
right yeah exactly that's right uh in an
event we're going to wish you like
everybody else like the more I know it's
a mathematical impossibility nonetheless
we wishing everybody luck thanks and
we'll send you to go rest and uh yeah we
might see you sitting here tomorrow as
well good game today very good very very
impressive so now we have one more game
left
and in that game we are pretty certain
that black is going to win not only is
he up a pawn a protected passer but the
white king looks now if you play King F1
and I play Rook
H6
uh if I play King H2 and you play Queen
F2 no not Queen F2 there's a queen sorry
Queen wait so maybe King H2 I think he
has to play King H2 walking into
Checkmate but yeah well I'm seeing that
the computer is not super ined about the
position yeah King H2 is better than
King F1 King H2 yeah King F1 is minus 25
so I guess not so good not so good King
H2
G4 the computer wants to play Queen
F2 oh Queen F2 here yeah I didn't even
see it was legal yeah it's legal yeah if
I can trade queens and I get M that
would be nice that'll be a significant
achievement however the computer follows
Queen F2 up with the following line
Queen B3 King G7 King G7 seven wow yes
but my move's better I don't think you
can take because then the B Pawn looks
really sad or the D Pawn one of them
goes yeah in the meantime our King is
just ready to no you have to you have to
play Queen F2 because you're getting
checkmated if you play Queen F2 you
won't get check agree's got he's got to
play it not
arguing not arguing I think but this is
like I think that that look is almost
contemplating resignation here no not a
good he can't believe it white won every
game why should he lose this game yeah
wh's four out of
four there was a US championship in in
San Diego or La Hoya there were five
players who used to play for Cuba they
all played for the US MH and they had
black in one round and they went five
and0
wow so what did he do what did he do I
don't know we'll never find out yeah he
play he played the non- getting
checkmated move yeah always a good idea
just look at Luke's face I think that
they the story of the game sometimes you
don't need to do more seems like he
wants to move now he doesn't want to do
anything
thinking and he did Rook E8 yeah solid I
don't get that move sorry he's in
zuguang yeah I would have played King G7
I mean I can play King F1 why can't I
just improve my position King G7 and go
up with the King yeah I would have
played King G7 I need to waste a
move a bit
strange definitely not changing the
evaluation of the game but what was the
he's just saying you're in zugang oh
King f one
yeah then I would play Queen B3 because
now the Rooks hanging and the B pawns
hanging with check oh
yeah yeah I like that he's very
confident with his I like that a lot
yeah but yeah I mean if I'm going to
make a move that does nothing it would
be king G7 right better than on G8 well
the comp is not throwning on that too
much no he's suggesting trading the
Queens anyway is the first choice mhm
alternative playing either King F1 or
King G2 funny after King F1 he wants to
play King G7 whereas Queen B3 looks
really why is he suggesting that move
that's really weird not that it makes a
difference it's just in principle
mm yeah well I guess we will find I like
that you like my moves better than the
computer yeah clearly that's good King
F1 Queen B3 and what is
the that's no
fun maybe he thinks something like Queen
D2 and after check King G1 the queen is
a bit offside G5 is being attacked yeah
if you go F6 maybe I can go something
like Queen C2 right never play F6 yeah
so maybe maybe that is the reason but uh
yeah in any event this is just uh I see
that L is already big starting to look a
bit
uninterested you know I hate position
like this but it's not quite enough to
resign on the other
hand no no amount of of of planning is
going to make any any difference
you have to White to Super cooperate
here to not uh for white yeah the past a
pawn is really strong and the black R
cuts off the white king
and week
yeah yeah was really a speedy round yeah
it's not yet 5 in the afternoon and
already most games are are done this
game is also well they wanted End early
today because they have to play tomorrow
at 11 o' so so they figured okay if we
have to wake up early go to S Speed game
today very
considerate also I think they were
really concerned about missing the
current Han Mike Hummer how so that's
why they had to finish early we almost
forgot about that that would have been
unforgivable well that's why Rex came to
the club today he to promote it right
yeah no he heard he's like wow I want to
see that
yeah and we have Chief TD Tony Rich
looking at his last uh assignment of the
day he's like dude if you guys finish I
can go home yeah he realized that this
is an early day
possibly but it's funny for an early day
we again had lots of excitement the most
the number of most decisive runs yeah
that's amazing yeah very straightforward
game some really good performances both
by Chandra and uh
Jeffrey excuse me you're all choked up
and Ru Lee yeah and Ru Frank Lee also
played a beautiful game today and like
ruing Le said half jokingly that yeah he
was winning in maybe half of his game
can you imagine if he actually knra up
Half Point extra from could have been
different this tournament reminds me of
sort of a sad story of this tournament
with all the wins this round when I
played in the spice cup once in Texas
there was an a group and a b group and
in the B group there were no draws
because we're not good enough to draw so
sack AAS blunder everything and either
win or lose and then five games around
every round had four decisive games we
didn't have three we didn't have five we
was in four then there was the a
group dra draw draw draw Win dra no no
draw draw draw draw draw draw draw yeah
and there and there were only I think
six players in that group so there were
three draws three draws three draws
three draws three draws and sometimes 10
15 minutes it's going to be hard to
promote CH this way no no Susan was not
happy Susan organizer people those
people weren't invited back um but we
made up forward with all of our our
terrible play so it was a very exciting
tournament anyway so attention was uh
shifted to the B group yeah and here we
see the tournament's about to end
players are tired but all decisive games
and we're going to see something similar
tomorrow when you have to win it's
actually a big difference in prize money
it could be a th000
$2,000 for all the players and what
about the seed yeah no obviously for a
lot more I mean obviously for the top
players it's very important but for
people third fourth yeah of course you
come in fifth instead of ninth that's a
lot of money that's a big Mone yeah
that's that's some good money yeah
especially for young
teens some people work the whole summer
flipping burgers for just what they make
in uh I I did it once doing Burgers
those are hard to flip yeah
tough rookie eight very confident Big
Time Advantage for bodc he's going to
have to be extremely Lucky Luke today
this kind of a slap in the face when you
play a move that yeah kind of seem to
worsen your position The Rook is less
flexible on the on the on the last
strength I'm guessing that now he's also
threatening Queen F2 King F2 Rook C8 and
The Rook is coming either to C2 B2 or to
C4 B4
yeah it's really
bad yeah what move can you play here in
this
position no that's why he played Rook e
he's like it's your move and every move
makes yeah he has an idea The Rook can
now go to the SE fall which he couldn't
from E6
right yeah look is like yeah this is a
big difference we're only talking about
first place in this tournament but many
players in this tournament could come in
anywhere between fourth and nth plus one
plus one and minus one could be four
places that's right and the way the
prizes are that could be $1,000 or more
that's right well we're expecting a
really bloody game tomorrow bloody round
tomorrow yeah first prize is 6,000 plus
the automatic seed if there's a TI for
first we're going to have playoffs more
work for us G4 MC mullner and Matt
Larson are happy or they're make
exception I'll tell you one thing if I
had black I mov you my
queen I'm not trading queens now now I
want to Checkmate the guy oh wow the
assessment also changed in Black yeah
now now there's no Queen trade so we
before we look what are you suggesting
any move Queen away any move any move I
don't care as long as we don't trade
Queens bl's game is Queen F4 let's see
what the computer says computer says
Queen F4 yay what's the second move King
G7 really still trading Queens wow yeah
yeah Queen F4 I think that here there
are like a million moves that are just
about fine I think that King takes Queen
followed by Rook C8 can not get any bad
marks uh Queen F4 like you said with the
idea of Rook
E3
and just tying him up completely King G7
preparing for an end game with a active
King well again I I feel sorry for l in
a position where yeah not quite enough
to resign on the other hand not
encouraging to play his face say
everything and Michael bodak is just
thinking of how to tighten the cruise
here
yeah it reminds me of Kim man CIS when
everybody's leaving with The Knockout
and there's always one there's two or
four players left in the
yeah that's right everybody left they're
going to eat now they're going to
prepare for their game and these guys
have to suffer that's right although
Black's not suffering too much yeah well
I'm thinking that
uh since we don't have much more to say
about this game the game is kind of
self-explained this is a good time to
take our last break of the day y uh
maybe the spectators can do uh multitask
and uh look at this game and at the same
time try to solve a puzzle that we
prepared yeah uh a game by one of the
players in the tournament why don't we
do that and we'll be back with you
shortly again with the final game in a
very very decisive day of games uh four
out of four with expecting five out of
five from the 2015 US Junior close Chess
Championship here in the chess club and
Scholastic Center of St Louis Ben fold a
Freedman asking you to be back in just a
few minutes see you
soon hi I'm Mike maeni I've been part of
some great clubs and now I'm part of
another the chess club in Scholastics
Center of St Louis right here in the
chess capital of the us our
world-renowned Center is dedicated in
teaching playing and promoting the sport
because chess has been proven to enhance
academic performance our Scholastic
outreach program now works with over a
100 Schools so whether you've played for
years or never before come experience
all the chess has to
[Music]
offer
for
[Music]
all
for
[Music]
la
hi I'm Mike maeni whether you play chess
for fun or want to boost your child's
academic performance come visit the
chess club and Scholastic Center of St
Louis right here in the chess capital of
the US from a welcoming diverse
environment to a Scholastic outreach
program now in over 100 Schools our
Center across from the World Chess Hall
of Fame and the Central West End has it
all so whether you've played for years
or never before we invite you to
experience all chess has to
offer and we have returned once more
with our last game in the live coverage
for the
2015 uh us Junior close Championship
round eight the penultimate round coming
here from the St Louis chess club and
Scholastic Center uh to my left we have
a legendary grandmas Ben fold and amavi
fredman with our great staff of
producers camera people audio people Etc
and let's see what has changed in the
game since we left it oh sorry there's a
puzzle first uh we decided that because
you have so many decisive games today
and you must have wck your brain at all
the tactics will give you one that's a
true gimme a very very easy one we can
see that there is a stranded Rook on the
C3 Square we can see that the Knight on
F5 is very strong we identifi the
weakness in the black Army we
immediately find it in G7 how do we
combine an attack on a stranded Rook on
G7 Queen from F2 to D4 a simple Fork
threatening mate and The Rook of course
black cannot prevent both of them and
therefore he had to resign of course
Queen F6 is the only move that tries but
then of course with the Rook on F1
opposite that Queen Knight H6 check
picks up the whole house so after Queen
D4 Grand Master aranov had to resign to
our very own Arthur Shen beautiful game
by Arthur and now we have the last game
of the
tournament and uh yeah actually the
computer gave something like minus 16
let's see what happened yeah the last
position we looked at White played G4
which we didn't like right uh Queen B3 a
move I've been espousing for a while mhm
Rook C1 and now instead of taking the
pawn stronger move Queen D3 keeping
total control of the position black can
I'm sorry white can't activate anything
uh and now white blundered white should
play Rook C2 and only be lost right
right instead of the king H1 which is
quite a bad move because now black can
infiltrate with and let's see what he
did we played some moves since since we
came back from the break right so he
Rook E2 was played right and then Queen
to G3 and now the computer was
suggesting uh a plan recommended Often
by vlast milort our good friend A4 A3 A2
and if black pushes that
pawn if white somehow stops it I don't
see how then he's going to get
checkmated right if you think about it
the Rook is at maximum capacity so is
the queen our King is very safe we can
go to G7 upon any checks therefore what
do we have extra we have the ace and the
a file right by just moving the a pawn
the white can't really stop it it goes
to A3 it's is protected A2 it's
protected that's right and if white uses
his resources to stop the pawn from
queening which actually I don't see how
then he'll get King is going to get F3
has to be defended by the queen on G3
Queen H7 Queen H2 is made if the White
Queen runs away exactly that would have
been the best that would have been the
quickest he took the pawn on D4 not
exactly a move that changes also a lot
of fun Queen H3 so maybe we're
threatening Rook C8 check and rookie it
not anymore right so Black's two pawns
up two pass Pawns and basically his one
threat Rook cck was stopped that's right
well other moves other than Rook E8 by
the way King G7 the trivial response
also stopping Rook C just stopping any
dreams of because black is going to M
first right um if black wanted to be
really fancy Rook C2 was on the agenda
funny way if Rook takes Queen D1 picking
up the Rook with check and a queen
ending with like3 pawns more yep and uh
yeah I mean this position is just very
discouraging L is playing by
inertia I think he played Queen H6 if I
see
correctly but what if you don't see
correctly then he play it still played
it I'll tell you immediately what he
did he played Queen somewhere but all of
a sudden I can see where he played Queen
A6 yeah yep uh I'm voting for Queen
F4 preventing any disaster oh he can
also play Queen h8 to be really annoying
now that he's so many pawns up that's a
nice Queen that's a nice would be like a
really how do you say a demoralizing
kind of move yeah because that's the end
of any Matrix he will never ever have to
think about perpetual and Luke already
has those gestures of uh just play that
move and I'll
resign of course any move will
do yep Queen E3 Queen F4 Queen D2 all
good que Queen F4 is the principal move
uh Queen h8 is the pedagogical move just
trading Queens the end of the Dream the
Dream
Crusher
you played Queen play Queen F4 yeah
reason very reasonable I wonder what is
the computer supp Jo we forgot to look
it'll be Queen
F4 yeah it is Queen a four and the
evaluation now is a very modest minus
103 well yeah the two extra pawns yeah
and uh now black has a second option
other than a A4 A3 is e D4 D3 D2 wait
did he play or did he he played Queen F4
yeah no but what did white play White
played Rook F1 d
def
yeah so The Rook can afford to return
gently to E2 right that stops Queen
taking you can't play Rook C1 again to
threaten any checks because Queen takes
Rook that's
right yeah of course any move wins
although I'm sort of kidding I'm almost
not kidding that white can try for some
stal Matrix almost man White's White's
running out of moves here yeah
unfortunately he is King G1 so
yeah but I don't think Michael play that
what did Michael do did he go D4 or
something let's see what did he play
played Rook E6 oh man that's mean white
wanted to play Queen takes B6 he
wouldn't let him yeah this looks like
resign time I predict resigns I
predicted
wrong Queen H even I would have maybe
resigned I predict King G7 I fiercely
predict King G7
Fierce yeah I buy it I buy it yeah I
guarantee King G7 and if he doesn't play
it I'll guarantee it's something
else so we expecting King G7 King G2 at
any second there can be a resignation
MH I think that we are King G7 res very
reasonable yeah right although Again by
iner every find every time he finds a
move he might
continue so what we're going to see five
decisive games today and we have a clear
first a clear second and a clear third
going into the last last round
yeah I think the Jeffrey must feel
pretty comfortable he's done all he
could he won convincingly today y he has
a the pairing the easiest pairings of
all against the lowest rated player in
the event who is who was in last after
after two convincing draws is back to uh
the losing circle after losing a game
without a fight basically against
uh Leo today and
uh I would be totally shocked if he
doesn't play King
G7 I I I'm surprised that he's taking
much I won't get over it never in all my
years
yeah of course the computer favors Rook
E2 immediately with total paralysis he
just
plays how unprofessional
D4 yeah white doesn't have any
counterplay so he's going to Queen his
Pawn
yeah and he resigned he resigned y no
counterplay no moves yep enough
suffering very understandable decision
it's funny that the move that uh like
the third or fourth by the computer is
good enough to resignation that's
testimony of how bad the position was
and uh yeah I'm assuming we're GNA have
as our last guest of the show today
Michael bodak we haven't seen him in a
while maybe he can talk a little bit
about this will Mike CER put the Kings
on the right squares no he put him on
the wrong oh no he put him on the right
squares I was just assuming I was
assuming he put him on the wrong squares
so no no he did a good
job that was his last Duty before he has
to prepare for tonight that's right yeah
now he's all ready for his own show and
let me Mark this up here five decisive
games as I predicted exactly like you
predicted exactly I'm telling you we are
going to play the lottery again yeah and
every number you say we'll play the
other one see I I I predicted five
decisive results about an hour ago I
have a better idea but not before I have
a better idea we're going to the casino
yeah we're putting all the money on the
color opposite of the color you're
thinking okay and I think we're going to
make a killing yeah and uh I'm going to
I'm going to predict the casino I put
the money on draw and then it'll be
decisive decisive when they take all the
money away decisive victory for the
casino so we are gonna wait for our last
um guest of the show let's do a recap
akot Chandra won against Arthur Shen
convincingly yes Jeffrey Jang W against
a wonder leang even more convincingly
yep and you want more convincing yeah
Leo beat Michael Bratton yeah M Bron M
BR I can't remember his name I'm so
confused yeah it was a very decisive and
uh some Lee ruang or Ethan so there's so
many good leaves in the US yeah Rachel
yeah Rachel's brother we can say yeah
Rachel's brother Lee beat Karan Hanan
again very lopsided game good and yeah
the last 25 moves of Harmon V bodc was
also one-sided that's right the game
looked like he was going towards uh
equality maybe even a draw not very
exciting and uh so five decis
amazing and we see mymer making sure
that the sets are ready for the ninth
and last round of this uh prestigious
event our cameraman Austin is again
preparing everything for the uh
excitement of the last run you know
after that that Victory by bodc we
should probably try to get him down here
okay so why don't we teleport him
quickly and very nice and we welcome
Michael again to the studio nice to see
you Michael you you ruined the day for
everybody a black one white won every
other game right was one one one one and
then all of a sudden zero I can't let it
be 100% that's right that's right we
can't afford to have now I'm sure you
were familiar with the game fine gold
versus his opponent I can't remember the
guy's name he's 2180 in this position uh
well I'm sure you're not familiar I'm
kidding it was in the National open in
2001 in round one and I played E3 and
after Rook E8 and I took he took on D4
he was not happy when I played Queen
takes C8 oh yeah so I was showing that
game before it happened we didn't think
that would happen this game no yeah and
your opponent instead played Knight
F3 and Aviv was falling asleep watching
this game I was falling asleep playing
this game there you go yeah looks like
it was pretty equal yeah can't say that
look was trying too hard I actually had
a draw in this line against the Cobian
too that was also very boring yeah I
mean I I wasn't happy with this line
there's I looked at it before the game
it's like every single games it draws
almost nothing happen there's a lot of
draws in this line no I think Queen B4
was this was the yeah cuz I mean it
forces my queen to see it but white has
to play B4 B5 yeah that's the normal
plan and here I just I just wanted to
provoke F3 to sort of just soften the
king side well you know the very
important rule never play F3 so you did
a good job yeah Knight F6 and then wow
King F2 and we were very surprised both
of us at the move H4 when he played H4 I
mean for a second without that without
that re well actually instead of Knight
H5 I mean actually after Knight H5 um he
yeah Knight H5 and then he played yeah I
think Queen H2 is almost winning here
after Queen C2 yeah I think and you play
Knight G7
yeah and the threat is Knight
F4 oh wow so he has to play Rook
E1 and then and then I play
C5 C5 yeah somebody wants to play D4
yeah then if if Rook takes then I take
on E3 and pawn takes then
D4 you must be the somebody and if
Knight takes D4 then Knight F4 and I
think White's busted wow
no I didn't see this till it was too
late wow so there was already a queen
H2 and if you take with the pawn some
other
tactics something wins something has to
win like yeah Knight F4 and then I take
on E1 yeah and well yeah this does not
Knight F4 Knight H3 with mate yeah wow
of C5 wow I mean yeah but let's see if
the computer agrees with your crazy
analysis not
I played the sensible move so this is
after Queen C2 by white yeah Queen C2
let's take a look what it says well
we're not anywhere near that yet Queen
several moves later and queen yeah here
in this position it already says you're
you're winning yeah with Queen H2 much
better and uh is Queen H2 The Right Move
no Rook something six
Rook oh wants to play like Rook E6 and
queen E7 oh well yeah that that too also
annoying I think yeah my position just
really great after Queen H2 he's
suggesting Rook e one right then we were
looking
okay let's take a look I'm curious why
is this happening play Let's Play Let's
play the line and see see the reputation
what's the see rookie one C okay the
computer is refusing he's very angry at
this oh okay then I'm that's a good
thing I didn't play it well no I mean it
just it just stopped working I didn't
see C5 so we're going to stop working
now
yeah but I think but you played very
sensitively instead I mean well I think
that a lot white got into a lot of
trouble from playing for playing F3
earlier yeah well said I couldn't have
said it better myself and the computer
says that it's actually not bad wow
after C5 he wants to play Queen F5 oh
wow aggressive and if CD4 Knight takes
D4 and holding oh oh yeah I think I
think how I played is more natural yeah
no you didn't play with computers are
bloodly finding those things so H4 what
does the thing of H4 okay the number
went down the number yeah I mean H4 we
were like wow H4 I mean if I don't if I
don't have Queen Queen H4 check in
between move that I'm worse cuz if I
just about a two points twist if I take
on G5 and Knight G3 I'm not playing for
a win
anymore and then this is this is not
what I want to get the best I can do is
Queen H7 and bail out to a worse end
game right and after Queen H4 you're
just winning oh yeah I didn't like H
takes G he
wanted no he did like it so why did he
take the assessment down he was thinking
more
right
no yeah it just says you're winning the
rest of the game
yeah and then now you're up better he
finally got B4 in yeah
yeah and yeah other games were all
getting we're ending here didn't like G4
I mean I think the idea of G4 is that if
the queens and Rooks are traded it's a
drawn Pawn end game ah very
interesting and the Compu here wanted
you to play A4 A3 A2 and give some
numbers you're not old enough to hear
really like 100 plus 100 plus 150 yeah
which happened anyway yeah A4 A3 A2 it's
hard for white to do anything I mean I
don't want to get M it by some trick
exactly yeah many every move one I was
suggesting you would play King G7 in
this position but you played D4 and that
was good enough yeah D4 D3 that a pretty
smooth victory yeah yeah yeah I think
most lackluster and you really made the
most of it really outplay the opponent
very good game I yeah the last dr's
actually worth a lot of money for
everybody I think like eighth place and
fourth place third place is like a big
money difference and why don't we take a
good look at the standings while Michael
is sitting with us let's bring the
standings up for everybody for the
viewers for the players that looks like
the standing no conference room and now
the standings and still alone at the
pinnacol we have I am AKA Chandra he is
definitely uh the most comfortable of
the players with six out eight tomorrow
playing
against uh who is he playing tomorrow do
shot's playing uh is playing under right
wonder that is right Wonder black
against a Wonder Jeffrey is playing
Black against Kon Han that's correct and
uh yeah who you playing more Michael uh
the well the one guy you didn't yeah I
know yeah usually I don't know this but
know y because I played everyone else
already you play Leo okay so we have
Arthur still alone you guys have the
same score oh wow so that's going to be
a money game I think this is actually
this is the closest matchup well you
have the same score so yeah ruang Lee is
in fourth place notice how first second
third and fourth are all alone and ruang
Lee could have a lot more points that's
right he missed he missed and so could
he on boy he's head yeah except for
today where he just rolled over his
opponents five decisive games today
Michael and Y are each other they have
four points Luke Harman VOR and Aang
must be very disappointed with the minus
one score well I wonder had two and a
half out of three that's right one out
of five not a good finish not that good
uh Mika is just not picking up any
momentum having just two and a half out
of eight and our lowest rated player in
the tournament the winner of the US
Junior open uh again lowest rated by a
margin of some 250 points but he can
really affect the results tomorrow
that's right he shows up tomorrow if he
decides to have the the game of his life
tomorrow he can definitely uh I know the
Chandra has a big bouquet of flowers
ready in case uh he scores not a normal
bouquet but a big bouquet a big bouquet
yeah yeah so uh yeah we're going to wrap
up the show and hope to see everybody
tomorrow remember two hours earlier
Michael has to remember that too I know
it's going to be tough but I'll remember
exactly 10:50 a.m. Central Time the
games will start promptly at 11: with a
very narrow tolerance for being late to
the game hopefully we won't have to uh
forfeit anybody please join us again
because again we don't have a winner yet
and again every game is important uh the
standings are closed every game means a
lot please be be with us and we promise
you lots more excitement uh from the
chess club and Scholastics Center of St
Louis for the last decisive round of the
2015 US Junior close Chess Championship
and make sure you follow all the action
at uschess champs.com for results
pictures standings that's right and you
can
watchos that's right wrap-ups by
grandmas McKenzie mullner who writes
Beautiful synopsis and game analysis to
the games and uh yeah for Grandmaster
Ben fold for I am elect Michael bodak
and myself see you tomorrow
[Music]
byebye